hey folks welcome to the Dark Horse
podcast I have the distinct pleasure of
sitting this afternoon with Martin agian
who is somebody you may not know he is
an author he has written a book called
God Bless America America spelled with a
k a book about your father's
experience um he is also a 100 years old
which I find amazing not only is he 100
years old which is a difficult
accomplishment in and of itself but uh
he in fact drove us here today um I met
him traveling all by himself uh on one
of the planes that flies up to the San
Juan Islands and anyway I was fascinated
by his story so Martin welcome to the
Dark Horse podcast thank you very much
Brett I'm happy to be here and my
pleasure I'm very happy to have you here
now I will say um you and I spent a fair
amount of talking time talking y
yesterday uh right after I met you um
you ended up having a conversation with
me with Gina and with Ray Gina is uh one
of the shuttle drivers at the airline
that flies up here and Ry is one of
their pilots and anyway we were um
engrossed in what you had to tell us
about your life and about your
experiences in World War II and your
observations about uh this country of
ours and about different Generations so
my Hope was to capture some of what you
understand about the world so that um
our viewers could uh could learn from it
also well I'll tell you Brett I'm not I
don't have all the guaranteed answers
you don't no there's no guarantee in
life I I had thought that you had all
the ANW I have some insights well
perfect that that that will do in this
case and they're not just the random
insights they're well figured out in
insights that become from part of my
philosophy of life now and Life
Changes was one of the philosophers in
Rome the um what is it epicurian people
epicurian followers of epicurius they
said all Nothing in life is um standard
nothing remains nothing is
um um without movement things change and
then they change again and again and
pretty soon you know recognize the thing
that you knew in the beginning it's
changed so much you have no knowledge of
how that happened and that's how life is
we're changing nothing abides nothing
and you have to make the best your own
way and no one has all the answers it's
a fight to the Finish and you better do
your best and that's all I can tell you
do your best and don't quit don't stop
always think if you lose you make a
mistake consider that a benefit when you
you lose don't cry don't blame somebody
else don't say you had the wrong Mom the
wrong dad or the school was not doing
their job you are responsible for
yourself so don't ever blame anyone else
just say I made a mistake hooray I made
a mistake let me correct that and not do
it again well I I agree with you that uh
these each of these errors uh as much as
they have cost you are also an
opportunity to upgrade yourself and if
you if you look at these things in that
way that does uh fill your life with
opportunity to uh to get better the
Japanese called it Yamato
damashi that means basically it's
untranslatable but it means
a Japanese
Spirit the the philosophy of Japan
whatever it is you want to call it it's
hard to translate like um Fulk in German
means people but means more than people
is something
deeper than just people anybody is a
folk it's a certain type of
people yes it's the it's the core of the
society core the very essence of being
german yes not because you eat sausages
and drink beer that has nothing to do
with it it's deeper than that it's
historically deep so yamashi to the
Japanese mean if you make a
mistake congratulate you made a mistake
but don't do it again right making the
same mistake twice that's on you right
now um among the things that I found
very interesting when we spoke yesterday
um was you were keenly aware of the
origin stories of the various people
that you had interacted with over your
life what population they had come from
where where they have immigrated from uh
you know in the case of you know the
Japanese you seem to know uh something
about uh the Japanese mindset and and
history uh you were a B7 pilot in World
War II um I know you were fighting in
Europe and not in the Pacific but uh
nonetheless the Japanese were the enemy
and yet you uh you are clearly
enlightened in the sense of
understanding that though you are
temporarily at war with another
population it doesn't mean that
population doesn't have something to
teach you
well first of
all there's nothing new on this Earth no
no Human Adventure no human thought no
human concept of anything governments
types philosophy it's been hashed over
changed rearranged and come back to the
original again but that was so far a
thousand years past and the people who
are present don't even know that ever
happened but they did the same thing in
Egypt in Jerusalem in in in the Middle
East in Germany everything is a repeat
only we don't live long enough to see
that you have to read it from the the
historian the readings or the wall
paintings or whatever is left available
to draw like if if someone found a um a
Coca-Cola bottle 2,000 years from now
they'll say they never heard of
Coca-Cola of course 2,000 years they say
oh there's some designs on that bottle
must be a sacred bottle you know on the
altar of the they can they can only go
by what they see yeah and it's only a
Coca-Cola bottle yeah you know I don't
know if you remember this I mentioned to
you yesterday that um that I'm an
evolutionary biologist and I spent a lot
of time thinking about why it is that
human beings make art it's a strange
thing because art is not productive in
the same way that farming or Metallurgy
is productive but um the hypothesis that
I have advanced is that art is a way of
conveying very deep things across space
and across time and in fact the example
that I use is the painting
Gua Picasso's painting of uh the bombing
of guica which was apparently terrifying
and devastating and he conveys the um
the insane destruction of this event in
history so that people Generations later
are able to Inuit it what you said to me
yesterday about um the hellish nature of
War um so in any case I guess our
philosophies um meet there well you see
Brett would you go today if there
Stadium say um Oakland Stadium where
they play ba football and baseball if
you would you pay say $5 or $10 a ticket
to go and see Gladiators kill each other
would you today no no would they first
have that at all they wouldn't have it
at all they wouldn't hold it it's coming
back I think no but violence maybe
physical things but not actually killing
you right right there on the with with a
with a with a weapon right so in now
days it's like going to the football
game you see they're still going to a
game they're still sitting in the
bleachers they're still chewing for the
guy they want to win and they're still
and the outcome is either death or at
least
leniency this the same yeah it's the
people sitting in the audience aren't
going to say oh that's not nice don't do
that well you know I mean if you'd look
at uh let's say professional football
for example these people are now so
highly paid but to put their health in
severe Jeopardy the toll it takes to be
an elite football player is actually
very severe and while they don't
typically die on the field it's not so
different from having people in a
stadium uh fighting for their lives it
is you know no those um Gladiators it's
a
profession they know they're going to
get killed or come out alive yeah in
fact they might even the emperor might
say or okay you should fight another B
it's it's all the mindset and the people
who sit in those
coliseums with the front row seats or
the way back in the back the The
Peasants these people come there they
they thinking of death
their lives are miserable anyways they
come in there MH they're people who are
starving and hungry and the elite seats
are someplace else but these people life
outside in fact most of these Gladiators
are gaining their freedom that way to be
an ordinary Citizen and so it's it's
just the way things are and you don't um
like my mom there's we had a Neighbor
Next Door no two homes down in in
Detroit and Harry Van was his name and
she she didn't want me to go into their
home I said why Mom I'm about 10 11
years old she said I don't like that
family Martin but Harry can come here at
our home but you can't go to their home
and that was her privilege as my mother
she didn't want me to associate with
people that would I would see things
that were not the same in my home and I
could be misled or be thinking something
different and my mom's and dad would
would be negated in other words in a
sense and I go their way maybe so you
see everything has it off to keep things
in focus and there's nothing wrong with
saying our family is different and I
don't want you go there with there
because all our effort is on you y and
so that's how everything goes the world
repeats itself over again you can go if
I can take you back to the time of the
Pharaoh what did they do with the
Pharaoh when he died mummified him right
what who else did they put in there uh
uh servants servants put them to death
yeah why they do that though what do
they believe well they believe there was
somewhere to go there's a life Hereafter
y that that's not Christian or judaic
that's not anything that's Egyptian yeah
they said he has to have his servants he
has to have his best um General he has
to have all the things the cup he drinks
wine out of whatever it is all in that
coffin in that pyramid or wherever
they're buried but they believe
earnestly that there is a Hereafter
and we do that today
too we don't put we don't kill your
mother and father if you die first and
put them with you you have to be with
your mom and dad yeah or a little baby
just born dies oh my God you got to have
mother there too kill the mother yeah no
we don't do that we don't do that but uh
there is obviously a continuity they
believe Hereafter that's my point Y so
um let's talk a little bit about uh
you've had various chapters of your life
um I think uh you know you've talked
talk to me a little bit about your
childhood um you obviously went to war
as a very young man how old were you no
no different than anybody 18 years old
18 years old and how long did it take by
the way I fought not really me infantry
whatever you're Marine if you're 18
years old you can go to battle and get
killed but you couldn't drink liquor in
a bar and you couldn't vote right which
is yeah I mean it's you stop the think
of it I can't vote I can't go to bar but
I can going get killed myself I'm get
killed you can die for your country yeah
um so you flew B7 bombers yes it's a
flying fortress Flying Fortress is the
name and I I will tell you um one of my
favorite books of all time is Catch 22
Catch 22 yeah um and I know from that
book and from reading a certain amount
of history that bombers had an appalling
rate of uh returning from a bombing run
that yes they were frequently shot out
of the sky yeah that
because at that time Germany had
controlled all of Europe they defeated
the British and the French at dunker
they they got went back to England and
by the way
Hitler had his
armies
stop before they got into dunker on his
orders and all his generals said to him
all the top generals the men who got
their War to that point now's the chance
we we can there's 400,000 or 390,000
troops Harden water War hardened troops
we can capture them or kill them no
don't go into dunker you know why he did
that no he wanted to do that because he
didn't want England he didn't he loved
England Hitler didn't want England in
his Hitler's mind England could have the
rest of the world he wanted Europe in
the Bread Basket Ukraine and he didn't
want it defeat England English was a
Germanic race the language is part Latin
part but basically it's a Germanic race
Dutch in fact in FIA that's part of
Holland FIA he to told the Army do not
do any destructions that's Northern
Belgium do not any destroy anything
there because I promised them I wouldn't
because they're be part of my German
Unity forces so this man was a super
super
politician Hitler forget his evilness
put that
aside just temporarily yeah this man
could bamboozle anybody except Churchill
Churchill knew this man in because
Churchill is the same type of a man he
is one that can neot negotiate and
figure out angles for good purpose but
also for England's purpose yeah and
Hitler was more overt you knew he wrote
it in mine comp what he's going to do to
the letter no one read the damn book I
read it four times it's all in there
yeah mine comp exactly what he's going
to do
exactly that's troubling um I will say I
don't know you know I I do know from
talking to you yesterday um that you're
not the most upto-date guy with respect
to technology which of course should be
a surprise to nobody um I I tried to
describe to you what a podcast was and
you know obviously it's not the most
intuitive concept yeah
but the internet um for some time I've
been quite concerned about the fact that
uh hitlerian thinking is returning and
I've been trying to alert people to the
danger of this and it's very hard based
on the way the internet works you don't
run into it unless you go out of your
way to find it and so peek and you shall
find it's there in and you know the
attack in Israel on October 7th has
brought some of it to the surface so
people who didn't think it was out there
are now seeing it for the first time
this episode is sponsored by biome maker
of knobs n o BS knobs is a new kind of
Denis Denis is anything you use to clean
your teeth toothpaste powders or knobs
knobs is fantastic biome that's biome
without the e on the end is focused on
Effectiveness transparency and safety
and knobs is a truly fantastic product
product let's talk fluoride fluoride is
the anti-cavity ingredient in most
toothpaste that you already know about
but as we discussed in our book The
fluoride in drinking water and
toothpaste is not in a molecular form
that is found in nature or that has ever
been part of our diet and ever more
research is pointing to the
neurotoxicity of fluoride especially in
children knobs from biome does not
contain fluoride but unlike competing
products knobs does include a different
and far better remineralizing agent
knobs uses hydroxy app appetite hydroxy
appetite is the main component of the
enamel in your teeth and is in your
bones as well it is as effective as
fluoride in remineralizing teeth without
the toxicity hydroxy appetite doesn't
merely stop cavities from forming it can
even arrest tooth decay once it's under
way knobs also has no abrasives like
charcoal or baking soda it has no
sulfates parabens phalates microplastics
no BS it's right there in the name
furthermore knobs comes in the form of
dehyd tablets which allows them to be
shelf stable without any preservatives
take a tablet chew it a few times and
brush as normal your teeth are going to
feel fantastically clean because they
are also unlike toothpaste TSA has no
interest in knobs because they're
tablets so if you're flying with knobs
you don't risk losing your Denis to
security so check out knobs at wwwb
better.com
Darkhorse remember it's biome without an
e that's bet t t r b i o m /d Darkhorse
listeners can enjoy 15% off their first
one-month supply of knobs so go to
better
biome.is this unfortunate view of Hitler
that is like a cartoon that because we
don't any longer understand that what we
are dealing with was a diabolical genius
diab that's a perfect example genius
doesn't mean a good person doesn't just
he's genius that's all whether he for
good or for bad but he's a genius he's a
genius and the Diabolical was carried
Along on that insight about people and
how to uh to Galvanize them um and so
because we treat him as a a cartoon we
don't anticipate the danger of this
happening again in some form um so I
worry about that a lot well you have to
have an a population that means for
instance America you have to have a
population that is well educated and we
don't we don't have that number one and
whose parents were well educated we
don't have that either maybe you could
go back to my generation we had a little
more awareness could just imagine can
you imagine if did
today I was Kindergarten or Elementary
School in my time when I went to school
sixth Fifth Fifth six up to eighth grade
K to8 the worst offense the worst
offense I as a student could cause was
you know what chewing gum and
clue chewing gum chewing
gum I mean they walk into high school
now with their belly button showing and
their tits hanging out I mean and and
and no one pays it that doesn't mean
anything they don't understand the
underlying um danger that's lurking in
the shadows when people lose control of
them they're all overweight oh yeah
eating all kinds of garbage and the
parents don't know any different and
they're all occupied with making money
buy more food and what go to get a next
polish fingernail you know those fake
fingernails they put on cost 60 bucks
and these girls have to work at a dice
cream paror to make 60 bucks to put the
damn thing on and then wipe it off put
another one I I don't understand that no
I it's hard to understand and I will say
I'm 54 um so when I was a kid World War
II seemed like ancient history to me but
if now you know I was only born 25 years
after the end of it um and we've now
covered more than that distance since
then um so by a lot and so anyway my
point would be
[Music]
um my immediate ancestors people I knew
right my relatives people aunts yeah
people who had seen World War II my
grandfather uh and my grandmother my
grandmother died when I was 13 but my
grandfather lived uh into my adulthood
he met U my children um all of the
elders
were very clearheaded
about the danger that something
hitlerian that genocide could happen
that it could happen here in the United
States and that you need anywhere
anywhere that you needed to be aware and
they were also very clear with us about
the fact that the people in Europe the
Jews who had died were the ones that
told them themselves that as bad as
things were it would pass that's right
and so anyway that was their hope yeah
that was their hope and they were wrong
and that means that I've been on alert
for my whole life I didn't think I would
live to see it but um on alert for the
signs that things were turning and now
they are turning at a rate that's hard
for me to even imagine
well that's so that's don't feel bad
because you're not you weren't living in
those countries at the time you were you
were in America you were
safe my Armenian
people are the um
first historical genocide of the 20th
century 1 million 500,000 killed which
is half the nation mhm half of the
nation was killed by the Turks and not
like the Germans methodical put next
case I mean buered in the
streets terrible things on the priest's
feet they nailed horseshoes can you
imagine putting horseshoes on and making
him walk on a priest's
feet not and anyways Terrible Things
raping women pregnant women get the baby
and the mother at the same time uh if
the baby's nice looking Bab baby take
him raise him up as a Turk and so we
went through all that that's why there's
some sort of a com I hate to say
camaraderie but some real feeling of
mutual feeling of being singled out and
done away with yep and uh and the
Armenians with that and they now they're
all over the world and uh doing and in
fact one of my Jewish friends said she
thinks we are one of the Lost tribes of
Israel up there and became cuz we're
like the Jews we family oriented strong
you know for each other and um have a
religious I'm not preaching religion I'm
not even denying religion I'm just
saying there's a unifying factor in
every some countries don't have it yep
but other countries or people certain
peoples do and it's too bad that these
Muslim people in today's uh the what do
you call them the um G the Gaza Strip y
uh what's it hamus Palestinian
oh butchering babies well I mean we have
to we have to draw distinction okay and
you draw the distinction correctly you
said Hamas I mentioned the Palestinians
we have to same they're on the same on
the same track
well no I'm going to correct you um
Hamas is Hamas and there are many
Palestinians who support them and there
are many who don't okay um so it is just
vitally important that we not mix those
two things but there are there are
clearly people who
are
unfazed by the violence not just the
violence but
the uh the barbarism that was shown by
Hamas which actually matches very well
what you were describing from The
Armenian Genocide it was not a desire
simply to wipe out other people it was a
desire uh to show the opposite of Mercy
to Delight in tormenting living people
mothers
children
um and that is about something that is
about not just replacing another people
but it is about
um well it is about fundamentally
dehumanizing them about well you know
Brett I I I I I'm afraid I have a
different philosophy sure and not
different it's um how can I describe My
Philosophy it's I'm not excited about if
what I'm telling you killing this
putting horseshoes on their feet and
nails and nailing
horseshoes that's minor it's the
mentality that when Hitler come into
power the German people in the some of
the the book I read fall and Rise the
Third Wife by William El Shyer they
didn't like Hitler but they he said the
man said at least we have bread on the
table mhm you see they they close your
eyes sure they were the Hitler had a
heart time to get the votes to become
Chancellor the people were against him
but business impr life improved and they
he got Czechoslovakia he got part of the
Rin land without firing a bullet Austria
my God then their personal and he played
upon that with her GS play the music
play the announcements and they were
convinced that this man was going to
lead him to n yeah that's it we're here
and they they backed him up 100 to the
very end yeah yes well you know the way
you describe the story which I think is
totally accurate based on my
understanding of it is that it played on
so theum me the Palestinians might be
against them but if they get their way
the Hamas people they're going to be
going to vote for Hamas sure he's
they're playing on what the Palestinians
want they want the power personally but
they'll get it through that back door
you know yes
although the thing that's so hard to
understand about what happened in Israel
is that the bar barbarism of the Hamas
attack guaranteed a reaction by Israel
that would be devastating to Gaza there
was no way that the Israelis were going
to act with
um
restraint because the degree to which
you know Israel is not a large country
the degree to which people almost
everyone in Israel knows somebody who
was killed or kidnapped
and the way in which uh families died
and Hamas delighted in it and recorded
it and called their parents to brag
about killing Jews all of
that was certainly going to enrage
Israel so that its
um its tendency to to behave in a
civilized way would be challenged by
just the simple ghastly nature of the
atrocities listen if you and I are going
to have a conflict I mean an argument I
hope it doesn't come to that no no I no
I meant an argument yeah and I see you
on you have one agenda and my agenda is
contradictory to yours because I'm
looking at my end of it and you're
looking at your your
plan the
Hamas doesn't care about beheading
babies or all the Hideous things that
they did they want Israel to attack yes
they're asking of course they're begging
hit us of course but when you say that
um that if Hamas delivers uh an
improvement in the quality of life for
the people of Gaza that that's how they
will get ahead what I don't understand
and what I don't think anybody
understands is how given what Hamas did
a powerful Nation like Israel was going
to respond in a way that can't help but
make life terrifyingly awful in God wait
you missed one more point Point okay
1937 the world's Olympic games were held
where you know uh Munich Germany oh yes
Germany Berlin Berlin wait oh I'm sorry
Munich is was in power then he was the
chancellor of Germany they took down all
the signs that said Jews not allowed to
be here Jews they clean the city and and
the German people happy they drinking
beer with they got their lunch pail
there and they got a job unemployment
been wiped out 6 million people
unemployed on working of course they're
building battleships and submarines and
tanks and whatever else and um Hitler is
the top of the world and the whole world
comes there they see happy people they
see happy German young people and they
can't get over it and youth clamps um
bicycle clubs glider glider clubs but
training for Air Force you see you learn
to fly if you want to learn how to fly
an airplane you go a glider first a
glider yeah yeah
when you take a glver you better know
what you're doing there's no engine to
get you out of trouble and you got to
catch the wind all the anyways um so the
once the Hamas gets the the Palestinian
people who want a peaceful settlement
just to have a country of their own
there's nothing wrong with that yeah and
Israel wants ancient history of Israel
is in all their history is written in
that one little area of Israel which is
now Israel Jerusalem you know Naz all
that area yeah and
and
if if the Hamas can do it and get away
with it a little bit and then defeat
Israel somehow they'll go with Hamas
they have to improve their lives first
and and Hamas doesn't want that he wants
Israel to strike yes and and I tell you
I I I wouldn't want to be a head of the
Army in Israel to make certain or the
prime minister metan if I could make
that kind of a decision because you have
to you have to be very brave and not
only Brave confident confident is better
word that you fight you're going to win
and metan yahu made an interview with um
radio commentator television Sean
Hannity he
said we have to go we can't afford to
lose we have to become Victorious period
there's no such thing halfway me meure
if you if you do little halfway measure
that's Chamberlain giving them the Rin
land that's Chamberlain giving them
Czechoslovakia and Czechoslovakia was
guaranteed by France and England that
they would come to their aid if they're
attacked by anybody not Germany anybody
and they never did they and they gave
Czechoslovakia you know to Germany give
it to Hiller he took Austria that was
easy at Le there most Germans there yeah
so you see Hitler had his mind made up
that's one two three then danzik that
didn't do it that the war started and in
too bad Stalin didn't read M comp had he
read my comp or had a any American
anybody had read mik comp no even the
Germans didn't read it yeah he told the
exactly I mean to the letter what he's
going to do to get power in 1937 when
all the Americans world came to the uh
brillian for the
Olympics they saw a happy not a phony
real happy people right he had provided
he had provided growth yeah no yeah no
unemployment nice clubs join Freedom to
go go go abroad do whatever you want the
people knew this man was their Destiny
yeah and by the way Hitler could not
happen in any other country but Germany
it would never happen in America yeah it
gets some something else something else
will be but not that way yeah ours might
be sink down down down and down in the
gutter that we have gutter rats running
the country oh I think we do yeah gutter
rats running the country gutter rats is
what we got yeah um so I want to go back
to a couple points just clean them up
before am I am i cring y too much no
okay I'm doing all right you're doing
great you hear that folks yeah um so I
wanted to um return to to a few things
here one I must tell you
um I am stuck in a bind with respect to
what's taking place in Israel because I
have nothing but compassion for these
Israeli people oh and I think you can't
help it can't help it you don't have to
be Jewish right you anybody any any
common sense right I do not feel like
Netanyahu is doing right by the Israeli
people and in fact I believe he put them
in a position where this happened so my
feeling is I'm I'm stuck because because
I'm told that I have to wave the Israeli
flag and I want to wave some flag that
allows me to say that uh I I am on the
side of the innocent Israelis and that
does not put me necessarily on the side
of the Israeli government which I
believe uh is in hands that are at least
through negligence responsible uh for
what took place so anyway I just feel
like that needs to be said okay um
that's of course your view right I'm not
I don't put that view on anybody else
but I just it is important to me that
unfortunately we live in an era where
people are waving flags and it's like
well are you on board with Israel or not
and it's like the Israeli people yes the
Israeli government is a very different
question and I wish there was some way
to separate those um but I also wanted
to talk you talked about the Berlin
Olympics it's interesting what made it
to my generation was not the story that
you tell uh where the world could see
that Hitler had delivered something to
the German people which explain expained
their allegiance right it was not
Madness on their part in some sense it
was um you know it's probably even wrong
to describe it as greed but just a
desire to have more of what had been
delivered to them um but what made it to
my generation was Hitler's refusal to
shake hands with Jesse Owens um you know
a black man who who won the race the
dash it was a long race he did a very
good job yeah he did a very good job and
Hitler Hitler um pettiness his
unwillingness to shake the hand of a
black man who had demonstrated
superiority was the thing so even in in
portraying Hitler as a cartoon character
rather than as a you know um a genius of
a diabolical nature which would you know
if history had given us that lesson then
we would be better able to watch for
such a thing one thing I add to that
sure Chamberlain y the prime minister at
the time y British Pres went to England
I mean to Germany to negotiate with
Hitler even gave him what he wanted even
some cases more than he
wanted the people the English people I
mean the German people didn't say that
they thought that was wonderful that
this our Hitler was negotiating these
things but if but Hitler was true to his
colors he never shook in the hands of a
black man cuz he was against blacks
completely and or race like the blacks
low
quality the unmention they call them
were the poles the Russians the Slavs
yeah they looked at everybody as
inferior yeah inferior subhuman and when
you think if I think you're subhuman you
better I better keep you subhuman or I
don't want you to get any smarter they
killed in the Poland it took about
3,000 no 20,000 intellectuals polish
intellectual not Jewish polish killed
them they didn't want these to be the
leaders on the ground to F you know
challenge the German rule they did the
same with the Armenian people in
Constantinople they took 28 of the
top um professional people doctors
lawyers Bankers hung him in the street
let him know that that's your future is
going to be that y so but Hitler was
true to his color he said I don't shake
a hand of a black man if he said oh yeah
I'm glad you Jesse
he'd be a
hypocrite he would be a hypocrite yeah
well you know the funny thing is he's
what I'm trying to show you is how
internally he he is what he is he
doesn't gloss over by being nice to you
then behind your back say he's a jerk
I'm not I don't you know all that stuff
he was true to his and the people didn't
see that how they couldn't see that and
read the mine comp have you read the
mine comp I haven't read mine comp it be
a replay of World War II everything he
said he did it to the letter you know
how he how he attacked Poland tell me he
took 25 or 20 men in concentration camp
who were uh you know there for bad
reason not necessarily Jewish but um you
don't mean you don't mean concentration
camp yeah they conc I mean prison or
concentration yeah he took them put on
um German
uniforms and had the gapo shoot him dead
and in the in the city of gtz there's a
radio station which is on the Russ
German side of the border between Poland
and and laid these bodies out and took
pictures that Poland attacked German
soldiers and workers in false false flag
that's the excuse that's how he operates
that didn't do right off the bat start
the war but that was all and then
Stalin you want to know something that
guy is really
genius he knew everything and he just
said oh yes like the Japanese a so you
know but meantime
their aircraft carriers are heading for
Pearl Harbor you know this is all fair
and Love and War I don't hold that
against anybody that's he he's on his
side he's fighting for his side for his
agenda and he can do anything he want
they even mentioned Hitler in one of his
they said if you kill all these Jewish
people then what was the he said they
killed all the Armenians and who
remember that he says no one remembers
it right and in fact it's very clear uh
from the history that um the Nazis
intended to cover their crime and what
happened is they were overrun by the
allies and so they were not fully able
to erase the evidence of the Holocaust
yes but that happened only after the
Allies landed on Europe and they went
they found all this information but
before that when they control the whole
continent they were having a field day
with people poles Jews Communists they
they every village they went into Russia
that had a communist commissar he's dead
and his generals were were against that
believe it or not they what that's not
that's not war that's murder hit says
you do it or you'll be
dead I mean oh it's uh at my age BR
nothing means anything anymore to me I
mean material things yeah I found a lot
of pictures of my my wife just passed
away like you know June I mean sorry
August 20th four months ago all the
things we cherish before material things
mean absolutely nothing to me all I just
save a few best ones I like and I don't
know what I'm going to do with those
either no material things mean nothing
yeah and you lose before you're saving
like in Ecclesiastes you you read
Ecclesiastes oh read Ecclesiastes 12
chapters I read it over and over again
life is vexation
and um what's the word when you think of
yourself only um uh let's see Vanity
Vanity there vanity it says at the every
every paragraph life is vexation and
vanity after I die the man is saying and
he's he's one of the Kings of Israel he
says I worked all my life to make the
castle and have the wealth and the land
and the armies and this I die and the
next person Wast it all what what is
this yeah no one even carries it his own
son won't even carry it on so let me ask
you this
um what does still mean mean something
to you pardon what does still material
possessions mean nothing to you that
that makes sense to me what does mean
something to you now what does
mean what means some I I have to narrow
it down it's not to religion because I
already settled that there is a God okay
there's no doubt about it we call it God
you can call it ASAS like an Armenian
and do do whatever
language the all preva intellect you can
see it
everywhere how does an acorn become a
big oak tree one Little
Acorn one little baby grows up to be a
genius like Tesla Nikolai Tesla and
becomes great something something you
weren't you didn't evolve into that well
here's the thing that's right I don't
have that evolution of Darwinism I I
hear you you said this yesterday and I
uh let me just uh make this clear so it
doesn't confuse the audience so I'm an
evolutionary biologist my wife is an
evolutionary biologist I of course not
only it's a mistake to even say that I
believe that we evolved from apes for
example to I yeah but I you know
yesterday when you I'm not against you
right of course no I'm for I'm I'm glad
you have your opinion and in fact I
would say the following thing it would
be strange for me at 54 years of age to
even correct a hundred-year-old
person whatever it is that you have done
however it is that you have lived your
life you're sitting here at 100 able to
uh come up with the names of uh
historical figures yesterday you were
telling me particular pages in important
books that I probably ought read um so
whatever it is you're doing works like
nothing I've ever seen before so who am
I to tell you you've got something wrong
in the way you see the universe you
don't have to say I'm wrong but you
could challenge me well sure yeah I mean
but but I but I wouldn't even do it
because the absurdity let's put it this
way at a factual level I don't really
have any doubt about uh the general
story of Darwinism at a practical level
I have every doubt you know does it make
sense yes a person can live a good life
thinking in this way but is it the is it
the optimal thing to pass along in order
for people to know how to approach the
world um I don't think we know that yet
there's a big gap between the factual
reality of the way the universe works
and the uh information that tells you
how to live what is the key factor in
the universe what is the
key factor needed for it to function
like it does the Stars moving certain
way the uh the Aurora and how it happens
the Rhythm in the what is the key key
word that would describe how this well
there here what's the key word that
makes this watch work well the the watch
works because of design no I mean
there's
Harmony everything moves accordingly you
can't have the little hand move faster
than the big hand because that only
takes the minutes the big hand makes the
hour so how can you I mean the other way
around I'm sorry you you you can't you
you can't you this didn't grow someone
made it this way right now that is a
very famous argument about whether or
not um the appearance of design if one
uh were to find a squirrel the squirrel
has the same kind of orderliness that a
watch does and so this is a very old
argument about nothing new the people
who believe in all almighty God right
call it whatever you want they know that
this this didn't happen
it has to be and I would I would put it
to you a different way and again my
thought was not to offer a challenge to
you on this front at all because I don't
know what the purpose of doing so would
be but I would just submit to you that
as long as we're down this
road that if there is a God that that
God utilized the processes of geology to
make the world that God utilized the
processes of evolution to make the
creatures that's your opinion right of
course it is you know why it's your
opinion you have no other
you're using a human emotion to create
an opinion no no no no yeah how do you
know that God did that
because um for
example Darwin
was offering a model for how creatures
would come into existence before he had
any information about how uh genes were
encoded uh or what they would look like
in fact it's the maybe the weakest part
of his entire model was where is the
information how how is it stored and how
does it uh interact when when two
animals
breed now that we know where that
information is stored that we know it's
stored in the DNA we have a mechanism to
look at the tree of life okay and so
what that each of those genetic
spellings if God had made us each
separately there would be no reason for
the morphological pattern that suggests
that all of the uh apes are closely
related that they are slightly uh more
distantly related to the the monkeys
that are not Apes that they are slightly
more distantly related to the other
primates that they are slightly more
distantly related to the mammals there
would be no reason for the pattern of
genetic spellings to align so well with
the pattern of morph ological form that
we see in the
creatures that suggests a process in
which those creatures really do have a
history okay let me ask you this uh a
lowly worm
yes has to cohabit with another worm to
create the create more worms right let's
take a crocodile all right let's do
crocodiles crocodile they have sperms
and they have a womb and they they give
birth to their babies uh they give birth
to uh egg they and they give the babies
come out and they're self-sufficient the
moment they come out of the egg not
quite in no there's no nipple on the
mother no but so it happens that I have
uh lived with crocodiles and I've
watched them do this and so the
interesting thing with crocodiles
crocodiles are a very ancient primitive
group but the mother listens for the
eggs which are ready to hatch and when
the eggs are ready to come out the
babies inside the eggs make a beeping
noise it just sounds like beep sing is
crazy and the mother will return to the
nest and the babies she will then carry
the babies in her mouth to a place a
hidden place place uh in the side of the
the water something under a tree and the
babies will all exist there the hatch
they're swimming and she's effectively
protecting them because they're pretty
helpless when they're small that's all
built into the jeans yes 100% 100% built
in if that wasn't the case you'd have no
crocodile right you'd have nothing right
the world would be nothing but trees
even the trees do this they have that
same in fact human beings are one of two
groups in which there is substantial
evolutionary information that is not in
the
genes birds and mammals that's the two
places where this happens in significant
amounts and it happens because parents
and Offspring spend time together ciles
are an exception they do that but
there's nothing behaviorally transmitted
as far as we know in birds and mammals
there is the opportunity for mothers
it's usually mothers sometimes in some
species it's both mothers and fathers
but mothers to convey information about
how to be uh a hummingbird for example
they can convey this information because
mothers and babies encounter each other
right in human beings this is the most
elaborate version that has ever existed
on the Earth where in in fact a large
fraction of what it means to be a human
being is actually not in the genes right
a human being raised without their
parent is not a fully capable person um
a human being raised by wolves to take
the how do you know they're human well
it depends what you mean by human I me
well you said human yeah no let's put it
this way if we say what is this person
they're they're Human by virtue of the
fact that they if you strip a a brown
bear yeah strip it fur everything right
to the skin and laid it out not his head
just body resembles a human being bear
sure and but just naked
bear legs they you know they stand up
they AR they're almost like human beings
human beings will never know the answer
Brett never know the answer we'll never
know because the almighty all preading
intellect which I call God that word I
was asking you what what what word will
describe is harmony okay Harmony here
here's the problem okay and I believe me
I did not intend to get into uh uh an
argument with you I'm not this not this
is conversation I know I I love it I
grew I grew up in a home where this was
perfectly normal and I I I love that you
also love the style of interaction but I
didn't intend to go here but we're here
if MH God created these creatures
intentionally if God designed the bear
separately from designing the human
being
then God very much wanted us to believe
that they had evolved don't even don't
even think that way you know what you're
saying already didn't want us to think
that way he didn't take anybody into
consideration this is the way it is
there's no he's not God is not saying oh
the people will get confused they'll
never never know the answer well but but
no follow me a little bit farther here
because if God created us as we are okay
then God created us so that we have
would have some something called
scientists right and he knew that what a
scientist would do but before you say
that continue what did God create how do
you think we looked the first human
being looked well depends just your
opinion I don't know myself depends what
you mean by the first human being we can
we it depends what you mean by the
person like we are today you got
fingernails I got the same fingernails
well here but we can go back you know we
can go back to the first modern human
which would be a couple hundred thousand
years ago or we can go back to our
ancestors which we're already on our
branch of the tree but we're not fully
modern so we could go back you know to
Homo rectus for example we go back even
further to ostop aines we have we don't
have all of the fossils but we have
enough fossils to be able to piece
together how we got here creatures that
no longer exist right they were outc
competed by their
descendants um and in any case what I
would say to you is nobody can rule out
the possibility that a God put us here
with a purpose but I would submit to you
one of two things for a purpose no God
just
created and he I have this is all this
this is my what do you call my way of
looking at I don't know for sure sure
none of us know we'll never know right
he said he didn't do that all he did was
create a place where people or or
animals or what you want to call us
could breathe the air that keep us
sustain us some could breede under the
water and they were fish they they have
to breed air the air that's in the water
oxygen I mean and so without that oxygen
they'll suffocate sure and if they don't
if they don't they okay and some became
laid eggs and some gave life birth and
some had to have a sperm in a in a egg
to
fertilize you can go on forever all
we're going to do is take our human
experiences and interpret that
our way that's all we have to go by
right we don't have now suppose million
years from now yeah they found a
Coca-Cola bottle yeah you already
already I told you yeah and they'd say m
what is this
coca I what Lang they don't what that
means like the Rosetta Stone sure they
interpreted that they found out a clue
Napoleon one of his scientists found
that and anyways they would concoct the
story that this is one of the Temple's
most
valuable people piece of ordinance of
the I mean on the altar they and they
sacrificed the they filled it with blood
and you had to drink it you know who
knows what they make out of they makeing
nonsense all in their own concept sure
of their own experiences right but the
thing about science is that science
allows us to take our expectations and
discover that they're wrong that's the
one Superior thing about it is that you
can have a belief about what something
is and if you do the science correctly
it will actually tell you it's not true
and so the story of
evolution is
either a hoax perpetrated by a God that
wanted us to believe in it or the
mechanism that a God would have used to
accomplish the creation of creatures
like us
or God really is a story that we impose
on this more complicated difficult thing
that we've happened on to God's an easy
answer not an easy answer yes it is he
can do anything yeah but look I've been
fighting a battle for a long time with
uh my colleagues in evolutionary biology
my colleagues tend to view religion as a
a phony story a phony story yeah I mean
the way it's laid out now you mean no
they I mean in fact uh you mean there is
no God a living God not only not only do
they believe there is no God but they
believe that people who believe in a god
are effectively fools okay and I try to
explain to them that belief these belief
structures that we call religions can't
possibly be a mistake which doesn't make
them literally accurate but those are
the stories that allowed human beings to
accomplish the things that they
accomplished who was the god of the
Greeks the ancient Greeks well uh Zeus
would be the top Zeus yeah he was the
top man yeah he was the god yeah do I
have it right is it Zeus or Jupiter for
the Greeks no no Zeus yeah and Jupiter
was second in charge and then the third
and then he had he had actually
Saints well so what you're describing
the Greeks had Jesus he became or the
Jews had against Jesus a lot of Jews
were for Jesus so Jesus became the Son
of God not he's she Jesus became
Jupiter and the Greeks and all the other
gods
Saints with lesser power but so you see
mankind it's hard to I'm you're telling
you're telling the same story that I'm
telling in a different way I'm giving
you conjecture I don't know myself even
well none of us do I mean I'm saying
Martin is this what you think yes that's
I'm trying to analyze it and I'm I'm
open for I I I believe it but I don't
believe it yeah but um you know the
marvelous thing
is you know Martin you're 100 years old
yeah whatever mechanism you have used to
navigate your life has worked really
well well I mean I'm sure you got lucky
I mean obviously you're a B7 you
obviously I don't believe in Lu I never
did now you have experienced no luck or
no random happenings I believe that
everything has a purpose now this is one
of my examples that I use when I uh talk
to my colleagues about
um the idea that things can be
metaphorically true even if they are not
literally true if a person believes that
there's no such thing as luck that
everything happens for a reason you can
if you want to if fits perfect for luck
well I word I think a person who
believes in luck is actually at a
disadvantage even though there is
something that I would say is literally
luck did you and I meet in that airplane
very lucky no I don't think it was luck
no it was meant meant to be well here's
the thing I don't know if I'm right
right and it doesn't matter
because my point would be that a person
who believed that everything happened
for a reason would be on the lookout for
opportunity all the time because oh
that's okay no there's nothing wrong
with but the person who isn't conniving
to look who come to a place I'll go for
that person to help me I think I like
his way he looks that's different you're
analyzing people you know there nothing
wrong with that the drunk next to him be
the best person to go to because he has
more knowledge of what you want to know
but you don't know that but whatever
happens to me before I used to say lucky
yeah
random
chance all that I told I met that Indian
boy behind me did I tell you that uh I
don't think so okay I was my wife was
very ill I took her to India to a
homeopathic physan a Dr fijar very
well-known man not some Hocus Pocus way
and so I had to go back we were in India
for one year I had to go back make my
income tax uh back to California and so
it took me two weeks to go and do all
that and come back to India again well I
never knew on my Visa in little tiny
paragraph in tiny letter you'd have to
have a magnifying glass honest to God I
see honest to God
have the magnifying glass to see what
that you couldn't come back to India
again unless you stayed overseas 6 weeks
if you're going out of the country you
can come back 6 weeks later so when I
was into to go back I get to the
airport he says you can't go back I said
why I got
the no you have to be there 6 weeks you
only been there two
weeks I said I know he say I can hardly
read that I just know by experience he
says all I can say to you is go to the
culate Belgian the capital of Belgium
what was it laab what is
it laab no I can't pronounce the word
laav Belgium that's where the United
Nations Headquarters is go to the culate
and tell them your wife is ill that
she's under a care I said oh yeah take
the K take the uh the commuter train get
there and they'll help you I did all he
said got to the consulate and the guy
was a
typical low bureaucrat who thought he
was the
king sorry I said
please and I my
nature uh I say please because I like to
say please but I like to take that son
of a and beat his brains out he
says I'm sorry but you can't go with
Hardy like he has control a small
bureaucrat who's got an American under
his Petty Tyrant pett yeah yeah and then
there's other Indians in line behind me
and they've been there for two days
three days trying to get through also
and I said let me use your phone please
we don't allow anyone to use a culate
phone what do I do got to go back to
America say there 6 weeks continuous 6
weeks and come
back but a tap on my back shoulder turn
around it's a young Indian boy he says
sir I heard everything please take my
cell phone make the call get what you
have to do and he's a on a vacation from
Cambridge he's going he very very
wealthy family he's been School in
England and oh I says thank you I'll pay
no pay that's free just take it he says
so I called Hotel I got the downstairs
boy he knows me I said go upstairs and
get my wife tell her to get a doctor to
get on his letter head right that he's
the physician and D D D D and that he
has to Martin has to be there so forth
and so on fine we got the and here's the
fact number of the culate the coun the
fact came in less than 20 minutes
perfect and he still was going to act
like this you know Sall me a little more
make me a sweat yeah and he
well I'll give you June
28th and little did he know that we're
going to go home on June 27th anyways
because my birthday is in June 27 and so
I said oh thank you very much so you see
that was Destiny if that boy wasn't
behind you can call it luck yeah I don't
like to call it look because it's too
easy I like then wait I'm not wait one
minute one more thing I got okay now
right I'm going back out to the train
station to go back to the
airport the train that goes to the
airport goes right right into the
station you know the train pulls right
in it's a commuter train and but takes
an hour and a half to get there and
we're sitting in the train and there's a
girl there and everybody speaks Dutch of
course and French there's an
announcement the girl said did you hear
that sir I know you're American I said I
don't know what they said he said this
train is being cancelled is it canceled
I have to get to I have to go back to my
wife and so on he says well uh let me
see I can go with you I I'll go out of
my way to take you two a bridge has been
weakened the bridge won't hold the train
whatever it was you have to make five
circuitous way to get to the airport you
wouldn't be able to handle that you
wouldn't know what to get off what to
get on I'll take it the first two and
then from there I'll go to my sister's
house and sleep there and go to work
tomorrow oh I said please thank you what
we talking like this walking voice
behind me sir I turned around short well
dressed I mean
elegantly dressed he's a clothing men's
clothing salesman in in Holland and only
the United Nations people all that get
the best you customade clothing and he
looked elegant it was a Ghana from Ghana
India uh China I mean Africa excuse me
folks 100 years
old and you're doing great and I'll take
you the rest of the way all the way
don't worry I'll stay with my sisters
and this and that oh I says thank you
very much and he suck with me got me
right to the airport and I would never
have been able to do that not in a
million years so you see I have to call
that not look random chance it looks
like it could fit that category wouldn't
it he's behind me that's chance why was
he behind me why was he over there in
front of me right right no I I get it I
get it I think I think um I have to call
it something believing in luck it is not
very useful um that's right I don't
believe in luck our is not luck here
this is meant to be let's suppose it's
luck it does nothing for us I accept
that cuz it could be right could be
right still sounds right it sounds right
and it's still useless um but okay so
this does sort of return us to the
question uh of uh you as a B7 pilot
yeah and by the way I'm the my crew n
everybody with my engine ER flight
engineer were 18 19 or 20 years old he
was 26 and married and we all thought
poor Jim he's old man yeah what's he
doing here and he's married on top of
that oh God he should be home you know
with his wife whatever that's us the
mentality of the 18 to 20 years made him
an old man and married made it even
worse go you know there is a line I
won't get it exactly right it's been a
while since I've read Catch 22 but
there's a line in Catch 22 to there's a
favorite section I have in the book
where a an old man the proprietor of a
brothel in Italy is talking to one of
the young Airmen might be natly and
uh the young Airman is saying something
about how he's young and he has his
whole life ahead of him um and the old
man has accused him of being old and he
says I'm not old I'm only 20 and uh the
old man says you don't know if you're
going to live through tomorrow you don't
get older than
that well something on that order asap's
fables you know the who asap's fables
and Jesus spoke in Parables and ASAP
fables is sort of a parable the one one
I'm going to give you is the the
wolf is just killed a rabbit and he's in
his hunger he's hungry chewing fast some
of the bones got caught in his throat
and he looks up there's a STK flying
above the air and up in the air and he
says Mr St looks on oh my God the wolf
calling me what what what is it he up
there you know flying gliding in a sense
he said I I my God a he explains the
situ he says please come down you got a
long neck and a long beak you get that
bone out I I'll give you anything you
want I'll give you money I give you
reward the St reward he comes down lands
about 10 ft away make sure you know this
is legitimate comes closer he is choking
he's dying he open your mouth puts his
long beak in there the neck in there and
takes the bone
out he thank you well the Sor backs up a
few feet where's my
reward the wolf Narrows his eyes and
says you got your reward you go back and
tell the rest of the stor you put your
neck down my throat and pick it up in
one piece that's your
reward you want a reward yeah that's
your reward don't overdo something be
thankful for what happened yeah see well
there is something and I do think this
is one of the things that um our culture
has lost track of there's
uh very little gratitude for what we
have and in fact it's part of why we are
now putting our civilization in Jeopardy
because we don't realize how much worse
it can be right people who are um
obsessed with uh small problems or in
some cases problems that are actually
fictional are putting the entire
civilization in Jeopardy of collapsing
by causing us to to obsess over these
little things and it's it's very you
know I think if you've
traveled you've seen War um you know how
bad things can be and so you tend not to
want to take a system that works and
wreck it in the hope that something
better will emerge in it's in its place
but um I don't know young young people
have it too easy to even know how bad it
can be you know don't forget changes in
the past where you had to travel Abraham
Lincoln what N9 miles walk there just to
go to church or I to school and now
things happen like that y I mean uh
imagine Washington coming here and
saying I want to go to Philadelphia it
takes 4 days sir you can fly from from
Washington you take a car and get there
and 15 20 minutes my
God he'd be shocked wouldn't he okay in
our point of
view the world is going Our Generation
I'm leaving this generation this life
next five years if I go that far I'll be
happy
the speed by which to things to take
place catastrophic things almost like
earthquakes just destruction immediately
is happening in in everyday life things
change things move new inventions come
that that negates everything else and we
go faster and faster our ends going to
come very fast Yep this world of ours is
going to if we're not and I'm saying can
we do something to stop
it I don't know no one knows that's the
normal reaction to that how do we change
today's education how do we change the
children's way they getting be educated
they're being
changed taught in such a way that is
contrary to every Common Sense normal
Common Sense yes contrary to normal
Common Sense yeah Common Sense babies
shouldn't be being they're giv the baby
in New York and and New Jersey I think
the two states the baby can come to full
term full term it's out of the womb it's
crying it needs and the mother can still
have the baby aborted
that's a law yeah I can't I can't speak
to what the law is but I will say that
the um tolerance for um abortion right
up until the you know till Beyond
viability up to the moment of of birth
is obviously
a a hazard to our most fundamental
values and yet people treat it uh as if
it's an obvious right you know the
best thing I can answer that is the the
Young Generation is worried about
pigeons and squirrels and and squirrels
being what you call exterminated and
lose their identity and animals are
disappearing and last of the polar bears
that won't be coming here next 10 years
and yet they take a baby and kill
it now isn't that a contradiction that's
worse than being an atheist that's an
atheist at least says there might be a
God I don't know well I will say I see a
lot of these issues um changing people's
perspective um is changing and there is
a lot more Consciousness now than there
was I agree with you that's good that's
a healthy sign it is a healthy sign and
I and I hope that people become more
aware um I want to make sure that we
talk about a certain number of things um
I want to talk about uh what it was like
to be a pilot in World War II especially
a you're a pilot and you're 18 years old
I mean almost 19 I put it that way I was
19 I graduated I was 19 from Marfa Texas
you know only a young kid yep and all
the everybody else is just like me all
young kids out of the 500 in the class I
was in class
44b the uh only 100 made it to the final
Advanced Training 100 made it to
graduation get the got their wings and
their commissions okay and at the advanc
training only one or two would be
eliminated and not because they were
incompetent they couldn't give more time
the government said you must graduate
this much people we need Wars going
on and good guys got kicked out but they
were good and they need a little more
time Y and our and our lessons our
Ground School had to be 90% or better
you couldn't get
89%
90% you might fail on that your physical
exercise had to be if you fainted you
better get off the ground buddy you have
and they had three instructors in
Arizona each doing 15 minutes a piece
they they didn't have to worry about
fainting in the sun you know anyways and
uh you're flying you had to learn how to
be Solo in 4 and 1 half
hours uh what does that mean that means
first day 1 hour and a half second day
an hour and a half of what hour and a
half in the air okay so you're flying a
trainer they they're sitting it's a open
cockpit yeah you're in the front and
instructor's in the back and there's a
rear view mirror up here so so somebody
takes you up an instructor takes you up
and you get four hours to to not one
time four days four over four days you
have to in that fourth day you have to
solo you have to solo you have to know
everything there is to know he won't let
you go up he just take I'm sorry I can't
pass you and we go back to and you your
whole world collapses okay so you okay
so you graduate you've soloed
I did what I supposed to do y and um
they everybody 100 of us did that okay
and then they shipped you off pardon
they they shipped you off to Europe no
no point yeah you're uh graduated with
the wings yeah and second Lieutenant
commission and they even flew in tailor
from Kansas City five tailor to take our
measurements so our uniforms would be
officers you know all right tight fit
nice everything normal and we felt
Superior you know so far it sounds like
a good deal but then I know they shipped
you off to Europe and you had to
actually fight then you had a then you
go to another transition to learn how to
fly the the plane that you're going to
fly the b77 in my case and I wanted to
be a fighter pilot but my mom and dad
thought in their own ways Martin please
go in a ship with there's another people
in it help you and you help them you
you're safer they thought my you tell
me bomber Duty was more dang dangerous
oh yeah right but they my folks figured
more people in the plane and said all by
yourself right it sounds better they
didn't have the confidence that I had
yeah they're parents only child don't
forget got it bad enough to have 10 kids
in one di one in an Armenian home the
sun rises and sets on that child m
everything
is centered on that child and and I was
a good child I'm I'm not saying that I
believe you I was a good I never but I
say good I didn't say m you want that
bicycle I never did that you can't have
a Martin we can't afford it okay Mom
that's I I know they love me that's all
I cared y they said no that doesn't mean
they don't love me they don't have the
money right okay I understand all right
so you trained on the B7
yeah so you trained together with your
oh yeah now I got a crew we met for the
first time you're meeting your brother
and brothers together first time you
were a family now on that ship did you
know at the point you were training on
the B17 did you know how dangerous
bomber Duty was I didn't care no one
cared I the more dangerous the better
that's my personality I like
to I just love the challenge I'm not the
only one they all like that okay so hey
what can you tell me uh about what it
was like to train on this plane before
you what did you think of the B7 oh the
B17 is a very very safe and stable
airplane it's noted for its its slow
speed but you could shoot two engines
out half the plane could be falling off
the wings it still can go and you can
still not go but you can manage it
somehow either to get back to the base
or land safely yeah it was a the B24
didn't have that luxury it had a thinner
Wing more powerful engines and could go
faster but couldn't wasn't stable on
damage yeah control the B7 was the
Workhorse of the US Air Force all right
and so you trained on with how many
people in your crew pardon how many
people were in your crew uh besides
myself nine others nine others and that
includes a tail Gunner that's co-pilot
yeah uh the crew the crew chief that
mean the man who handles all the engine
possibility and all he handles the
invested men he's a sergeant yeah and
the rest are all privates and the the
officers are co-pilot pilot Navigator
and bombarder that's four officers and
there's six enlisted men with the crew
chief being in charge of them because
I'm in charge of everything as a captain
of the ship I mean I call it Captain I
wasn't a captain but I was yeah yeah the
head of the I was I was the king in the
ship yeah my law was my law and you obey
me but I never acted that way only one
time they came to my room I'll never
forget this knock on the door this is in
Florida we're ready to go overseas now
we we're all
together co-pilot Crew Chief and a
couple other guy they used to call me AG
Gan you know yeah we had I didn't care
they call me mran or call me Lieutenant
I didn't we all had a family he says can
we talk to you I said you look what's
going on come on in what is the problem
was I don't go out with the boys and get
drunk all the other Pilots go out and
they do that they with but you don't you
don't even go out with they're crying we
is is that is that the problem I said oh
my I said you know you have a right to
change if you don't have it you have it
in the Air Force if you don't have
confidence in the pilot you can ask to
be sent to another crew yeah if you
think he's not a good pilot you know no
it's not that you got to get drunk
that's easy let's go on and get drunk I
got plastered and they brought me back
holding me like like this I couldn't
even sleep the guard at the door at the
gate from then on smooth sailing smooth
sailing all right so they shipped you
out where did you go in Europe we went
to um a place called melam It's a small
village on the East Anglia and that part
of England if you shap like a thumb like
like like Michigan yeah yeah like a
glove okay we're right about there right
about there and right about in an arbor
yeah that's right uh it's um called
menam it's a
maybe 75 people live there family 75
families the nearest Big Town is felixo
or ipswitch that's over here 22 miles
across channel to France yeah so we're
right there and uh then you're part of a
group I was a squadron 18 and then you
fly missions oh first they sent me up
with a with an experienced crew to sit
as a copot yeah so he can evaluate me me
when they when I see all the action
going on would I do I panic or something
then he would report that you know so I
was leg looking for trouble that's I
just love this the excitement yeah I'm
I'm not I'm not being unique everybody
did it yeah we thought was great
Lieutenant I remember being 18 you know
yeah I could imagine nothing bothered me
and I looking forward to well you
whatever it is anyways then you fly with
your crew the next mission you passed
the that little test and that day we
went to Keel Germany Keel k i e l is a
with a submarine pens M and and that's a
big bombing that's a they're guarding
that part of that that pits yeah the the
the undercover 18 ft D thick cement
roofs yeah you couldn't penetrate that
stuff yeah and we had to bomb that drop
in bombs and sort of at an angle oh to
scoot it on yeah yeah we couldn't do
that too well be tried it yeah that's
not easy to do no it's not not bombers
in a group that individual playing can
do that they never come back alive yeah
and anyways and I know it's all the
black puffs of smoke quack crack I mean
no Flack
Flack sorry folks when you get 100 years
old you know what I'm talking about no
they're not going to make I like this
man he's a wonderful guy and I'm getting
all excited anyway we uh that was it
that was it okay so um you know it's
funny uh my
generation you don't know this cuz we
haven't really talked about uh what this
podcast is and all of that but um we
have an expression we use which I often
have to explain to people because they
don't have a relationship with it you
know if somebody is getting beaten up uh
in the world socially uh we'll say
ostracized some way yeah we'll say well
that's Flack over the Target that means
you're doing the right thing don't get
the wrong lesson from the fact that
you're taking Flack because it means
this is a heavily defended position
anyway you've actually faced actual flak
which I will you tell me if I've got it
wrong but Flack is basically shrapnel
shrap shot into the air 88 mm Cannon exp
they they they they calculate your
altitude not right to the yeah nth
degree but thinking pretty close and
they just fire fire fire and pieces of
metal shrapnel they call that uh many of
us had holes in the airplane or or
fighter pilots bullet
holes if you figured out the the way it
came he missed your nose Maybe by that
far away you would have been dead no
doubt about it so it's it's dangerous I
mean it you did you lose any members of
your crew never lose never lost never
never lost I only uh uh what do you call
it had a Harry Arnold he's passed away
now it's okay Harry Arnold was my waist
Gunner while we're in the thick of
battle you're not I mean on the Final
Approach to the Target that's about 3
minutes away airtime every plane locks
tight so that all the bombs would fall
concentrated on on our Target yeah
that's 40 ships all dropping bombs yeah
almost two seconds after the lead ship
drops the smoke bomb we drop ours
simultaneously for all intents and
purposes
Harry I'm hurt on the radio to me ag ag
oh my God I said to Jim so this is your
you said waist Gunner waist Gunner yeah
and waist Gunner is not the little ball
no no that's a turret underneath yeah
that's a ball tur yeah waist gun is just
a window and his gun has a very side
mounted yeah he can't go it's about a 45
degree from Center yeah you know 2 2 and
1/2 degrees this way 2 and2 degrees that
way so wait he has the ability to go
either side with a gun so he's in the
middle yeah and he has the caliber
machine guns two of them and they fire
fire simultaneous and the 50 g 50
MIM Cannon of a bullet is
about 6 in Long 50 caliber yeah most of
his armor piercing a lot of lot of
powder behind it yeah boy that if it
hits an engine it tear the engine to
pieces and this is to shoot down
Fighters that are after you is yeah our
are 50 caliber but the Germans didn't
have they had 30 caliber M which was
less but they could fire whatever that
was their way of doing it yeah so I'm
all I got all excited so Harry calls on
the radio inter yeah and that intercom
doesn't go to the rest of squad the
group I can only here or the rest of the
crew oh God they all got excited and I
said um to Jim my the flight Chie flight
crew chief the sergeant I said Jim go
back there and see what J
help AG yeah he's only
joking
I I want to tell the Copa Take the Wheel
I'm going to go pound
that I said Harry what I I I couldn't I
couldn't speak right in fact the plane
was got me so excited I I got out of
formation sort of
like all this took about 5 minutes to go
crawl back to the that part of the ship
anyways I don't know how I was going to
rep him man I didn't know how to do it
but they do the crew they said he comes
to my officer's quarters comes to my
quet Hut you know these round Huts metal
huts yeah they're called quanset
corrugated yeah corrugated right that
was how they put them really real we
lived in those Mass bunks inlist men
that live the same way as we did nothing
no segregation any we there and the he
is hairy he's got his duffel bag all the
clothing in it and everything they won't
let me in there they kicked me out I
said you deserve it it's going to rain
tomorrow I guarantee you I don't care if
snows no anyways Harry I said come on in
here put your get on and sleep on the
floor tomorrow I'll get you back in the
don't you know I know it I okay man only
body got wounded in my plan oh man
that's incredible so okay how many
missions did you fly 15 15 missions you
you don't fly one after another you
never oh
never too much sometimes some are milk
runs yeah very few of them but they're
milk runs compared if you compare milk
rat so milk rats a long time for that
that means it's an easy easy uh it's an
easy run and and by the way 4:30 in the
morning you've already had your
breakfast and you sit in the room where
the inter the the commanding officer is
going to tell you about the trip you're
going to take that day the mission yeah
and it's on he's on a stage maybe a foot
and a half higher than the floor and
we're sitting down here all Pilots
Navigators and
bombers and the curtain covers the map
and on that map a bunch of pins and
there's a a a yarn going the direction
to where you're going to go Y and on
purpose they move the the the curtain
slowly where are we going you don't he
don't say we're going to go to Berlin
you know we're all
watching and the curtain and the colonel
stops scratch I got scratch my nose a
little bit boys je pull the curtain he
pulled the curtain oh my TIR is on right
and finally we see the the yarn ends
Regensburg ballbearing factories oh
there's a groan in the audience anyway
that's just fun yeah then we get down
there get the mission then we get in our
planes and we take off by
Squadron for we get into the get to the
town of Felix
though the first plane probably pulls in
there around 5:00 the first group yeah
then 3 minutes later the second group
this is all Precision work within 15
minutes so we have a bomber stream of a
thousand ships a thousand ships
wow and in one half behind each other
yeah PR I call it 40 there's 38 but 40
ships in a
group and we're heading for
Regensburg but we're not going we we try
to be evasive we go this way ah they're
going to go to Hamburg no we're going to
the Germans are trying to guess where
we're going yeah so we at the last
minute they they know now Regensburg and
you know every German Squadron on the
ground fighter planes are notified and
they're up in the air they're going to
make hell for we're going to pay for
hell
anyways uh that's how this handled
sometimes we go to we go then we split
one goes
to no rupin another one goes to scheim
Airfield in Austria try to confuse the
enemy as much as we can sure now uh what
percentage of uh bomber Crews get shot
down yeah I don't know but it's not it's
not a few because a lot of bombers yeah
and if you I'll tell you if you lose out
of your group
six planes that's six out of
39 yeah that's heavy yeah that's a whole
crew airplane yeah and all those Crews
been trained now you got to got new
batch to train them you you like they if
they we sank seven German submarines
that's a lot of submarines because they
had to get a crew they got to get make a
submarine it's big instead you don't
just get pick a guy from the street and
put him in a submarine absolutely yeah
it it helps seven if you lost 15 out of
the oh that's horrible yeah that that
doesn't happen very often yeah but
you're wounded people yes but not
wounded people who got hit by flag or
bullets or killed in the airplane yeah
yeah has to be terrifying uh either to
watch planes presumably you knew all of
these Crews you were living together on
the same basis
well you know there's no explanation
it's for an 18 19 year old kid this is
fun honest to God I and I say fun I
don't mean we're enjoying killing people
right cuz we don't see that right but
you do have a thrilling meaningful job
do I'm doing my job they're trying to
stop me I'll show them they won't get me
whether I'm an American or a Canadian or
I'm I'm a Russian I don't care who I am
I am just doing my job I've been and I
appreciate that they train me yeah I my
loyalty is that flag American flag and
my mom and dad wants to see me again I'm
going to come home I don't think of
dying yeah the other gu going to die but
not me you know that's the mentality
right um and we don't want the other guy
to die either you know right now
uh things have gotten all tangled uh in
the uh last many
decades obviously the Russians were not
only um allies but they were
really you mean the Russia the World War
II yeah they were uh a major part of why
the Allies won they not not really major
the they were the reason the important
element that Hitler had to overcome or
we could never have done it right so
this is the thing that Americans often
don't get yeah the Americans don't know
that and even though they were
Communists right Stalin who was just as
bad as Hitler yeah oh in fact maybe more
I mean more Sinister yeah and anyways
but the Russian army navy what whatever
military force you want to give without
their and vast resources the depth of
the country they moved whole factories
out from the Moscow and Leningrad moved
it like moving New York to Nebraska yeah
intact Machinery the imagine the
turmoil Transportation feeding these
people they made Hitler pay for it yeah
early in the war 19 he hit Russia 1941
June by
1942 Hitler was finished he didn't know
it and the Russians didn't know it
history tells us that's the important
things to happen that that was the
Russians not the Allies yeah well it
it's a really important piece of history
and the fact that the you know a the the
difficulty you know Stalin was a
tremendous villain but he was Uncle Joe
Stalin during World War II that the the
the Allied powers the need to defeat
Hitler you know it at least Stalin it
was so much wor Hitler didn't kill
Germans Stalin didn't he killed Russians
yeah his own people he's not Russian he
was a he was a Georgian but he was part
of the Soviet Union anyways he killed
his own
citizens just wipe him out yeah he was
he was definitely diabolical but you see
even that
diabolical he became strong enough now
this is what what I would come it's not
luck I say it's not luck that's Martin
talking yeah you might say that's how it
happened no no I don't think that I
don't think most of what matters is luck
no because in fact luck you know it
plays
as a role that's positive as frequently
as negative that's the nature of luck
well Stalin knows that the Western
countries hate communism yeah Russ I
mean America London England France Che
hated communism
yeah but he acted like he didn't know if
you read the the minutes of meetings
they had and how the Diaries of the
Germans generals and he acted like give
hit everything he wants they praised H
oh I'm glad you won that battle you got
to kick the French out you got control
the German Army we we drink our vodka to
him every day and so and he Bamboozled
these d D Germans were supposed to be
very
smart they thought but they were so
eager to get Russia the Ukraine the
wheat the grains oh yeah in fact they um
I've
forgotten I'm going to get the German
word wrong even the Elbow Room oh no
labor Labor's real yeah the the the
future of Germany lies in Russia that in
the East he said and what's East Poland
Russia Ukraine the vast resources and
that was in his comp yeah he wrote that
specifically you got to be a not
to know that East means Poland after
Poland Russia that's how can you go
wrong right no it was a it was a a an
ingenious and diabolical plan yeah um
you you can call him whatever you want
but he's a very evil man but very evil
genius yeah well people uh you know it's
the problem and I think this is putting
us in great great
danger when somebody is
terrible we want to attribute everything
that could be wrong with them to them
which is a it's a terrible mistake so to
view um you know either Hitler or
Stalin as uh you know mentally
defective uh by virtue of the fact that
they were uh
ruthless is a mistake and it means that
we don't ly anticipate what the next one
will look like because the next one is
you know not going to match the cartoon
that we've painted of our enemies so
anyway I do think you know we are we are
headed to some new tragedy of history
and it's not going to look exactly like
the tragedies of the past but uh we are
going to fail to anticipate it when in
fact we should have been we should take
ourselves uh we we should have been
warned we were warned you know the
cartoon you make a point that he's evil
but they make a cartoon out of it yeah
as if you know like funny mustache or
whatever it is or big belly or whatever
but don't forget that cartoon is not the
evil man you think he is that's no
different they made cartoons of Lincoln
they made Lincoln look like a gorilla
did you know that I think I've seen that
yeah yeah his body was
disproportionate 6'4 184
lb his torso was normal legs were long
should be shorter for man with that kind
of a torso and his arms were longer yeah
so and his face wrinkled you know how it
is yeah they made him look like a
gorilla our own president yeah so that's
standard and and if you're and if you're
the Southerner Ah that's the gorilla if
you're northerner how dare them do that
you know yeah it's it's the same team
nonsense but the cartoonist is doing
that because he has a certain agenda
yeah and his agenda fits a certain group
of politicians and they go ooo good you
know so cartoons I can make a cartoon
out of you and make a cartoon out of me
and no I look like a horrible person you
know I mean gorilla or something
sure okay um so we've talked a little
bit about uh how long when what period
were you fighting in Europe what what
what years were you in in Europe
fighting uh what years were you flying
your your combat yeah that was
1944 until the end you were there at the
end yeah yeah June so January through
June 44 January through June of 44 yeah
where they were throwing everything at
us yeah and we had already landed on
Europe so we weren't we were still
flying from our our British era yeah
your base Bas but the target was getting
closer and closer and so we can move
fighter planes in France who could
protect us all away almost but they got
they took a beating and a lot of those
fighter planes the Germans were sending
train loads of you know ammunition food
and troops they did most of the strafing
to get those that's how erns R RL RL the
German general they call the desert fox
a very nice man I mean as an enemy the
British uh respected him he he was he
was a gentleman fighter I mean he wasn't
a
Nazi he was a good man doing his calling
and his country you know and he says and
he one of his I cannot do what I I have
to follow orders like The Men Who under
me follow orders a very kind of a man
you you want as a friend not military
yeah and if you needed some help next
door neighbor he come over and give you
anything you want help you yeah my uh
viewers are going to struggle he
extraordinary man we uh he was strafed
unknown The Fighter P-51 straved his
automobile when they were trying to rush
to the front and he had a terribly uh
hurt injured and he was almost going to
die but he was also working behind
Hitler's back to overthrow him really
yeah Hitler found that out through
through himler the chief of the
Casto and they sent two men to his home
but while he's recuperating he had
terrible injuries in the plane they shot
him and and his home he has a wife and
one son
and and they they come with they G they
gave an different excuse why they're
coming there when they got him in
private they said here's the
pill have to commit suicide we know what
you've been doing on the side trying to
overthrow Hitler and so take your
choice pill and then we'll give you
honorable burial you'll be a hero of the
of the Reich and you'll be
highly honored will never mention that
you were fighting against Hitler trying
to overthrow Hitler or if you don't your
family will be shot wife and child what
can a man do he took the pill yeah he so
they took him out someplace and the
mother and son think was the son was
brought there because he was in a
uniform too um on leave his father was
injured you know yeah
and he took his own
pistol blew his brains out they took
them gave him a burial and told the
mother and the son one peep out of you
and you're
dead to this day and now I don't know
any of that history so there are you
see things happen
um if you follow those things look at
the gr Grand
picture pretty soon it's a it's a it's
sort of a a drama shakes said what fools
we Mortals are mhm what fools Mortals
are and by the way
Shakespeare Sir Francis s Roger Bacon
you know you hear of him well the I've
been struggling with this question
myself because I've become aware of
evidence that bacon actually was shakesp
that's right and um the the Shakespeare
his real name was Shakespeare there was
a guy named Shakespeare but it's not
clear that he did the writing no no I'm
his name was Shakespeare yeah William
Shakespeare yeah and one way is spelled
SP p a r another time SP e he e r you
know whatever it is Shakespeare never
finished school yeah his daughter was
couldn't even read or write yeah and
here's a man who's writing things that
impossible for this man you know to do
that right and even more I mean I don't
know if it was bacon that's not the only
um hypothesis of of who it might have
been but how marvelous if it was bacon
because that makes bacon like a da Vinci
like intellect yes right just uh an
impossibly um deep thinker somebody as
expert in science as he was in a genius
Beyond genius yes yeah yeah and by the
way did you ever read you know who um
manly Hall is no oh my God you know
you W get go manly Hall manly Hall
manly
um wait
Manley there's initial there doesn't
Manley Hall HL yeah Palmer Manley Palmer
Hall yeah he has a he's dead now you
talk about get the book he has written
all kinds of books get the big one
that's 125 B I got that one yeah and I I
got it and I gave it away after my wife
passed away I nothing means anything to
me yeah I I've done my mental arithmetic
on all the things I've read I know what
I know what I don't know what I don't
care what I my philosophy of life is
Carry Me Through right to the end so
you'll have the same feeling too when
you get to the point where Martin what
am I doing all I don't need all that
stuff yeah the stuff means nothing but
you have children yes I do which you can
leave it to them yeah but I had nobody
to leave it to we had no children and
anyway it's a there's so many things but
I remember I told you the Admiral bird
to get that book did I tell you that uh
you did alone the word is alone alone
get that book audience get that book
beside my book get that
book uh uh he wrote page 160 164 the
whole book is only worth those three
pages there other part is very good but
it's all about but the price of
admission is in those three pages that
covers everything we're doing right now
yeah it gives you my opinion exactly to
the letter all right and this
man Admiral bird is a very known family
in Virginia senator bird his
great-grandfather I mean grandfather and
his father were both senators from uh in
fact his grandfather great-grandfather
just died he was a senator from Virginia
great grandson uh Tom the author of the
book alone M Admiral bird oh his
grandfather Yeah his great great
grandfather great grandfather Yeah so
anyways that book alone is an excellent
book just those four three four pages
all right
so I want to draw a little odd
connection here um I learned about the
evidence that bacon was
Shakespeare from is I hope he will not
mind me describing him this way he
actually I know he sometimes watches the
podcast uh a young man named Marvin very
unusual young
man and I did not meet Marvin until we
were moving out of our house in Portland
and he started to come by to visit um
how old is
he must have been 14 15 something like
that young man and he actually asked if
he could as we were moving out literally
moving out of our house we had a piano
which we couldn't bring here um we just
didn't have enough space for it and he
asked if he could play it and he played
it marvelously just a very concer penis
yeah gifted young man um and anyway he
he was also very uh intelligent you know
books smart and Beyond and and artistic
he actually Drew beautiful renderings of
multi- Challenger those are
yeah exactly and he at one point started
talking to me about the evidence that
Shakespeare wasn't Shakespeare and that
in fact bacon had been Shakespeare and
at first I thought you know the uh
strange ravings of a young man but he
convinced me that actually this uh
hypothesis was actually more likely true
than false so anyway I mention it
because a unusual person viewer of the
podcast deserves to be mentioned the
fact that I even know that bacon uh May
potentially have been Shakespeare I owe
to this young man and that's happened to
me many times I've learned a lot from my
own students and I learned from this
young man but I know that your
career was spent as a teacher I know
this because you told me yesterday and I
know that you were a teacher of troubled
young men is that fair me yeah no I was
a troubled man no no you were a teacher
of troubled oh yeah oh young boys only
gave me a special class of uh 12 I think
it was or 11 or 12 uh 12th graders that
were next infract infra infraction of
the rules of school expulsion they were
exp go find yourself in the school
district budy we don't want you so you
got a collection of these bad boys bad
boys bad boys tortured boys not bad
they're not bad they're tortured I know
because you told me as you were
describing this to
Gina uh and Rey and me um
yesterday uh you said that you had
actually been happy to get this
assignment I like I I'm made for it yeah
I know in I'm made for
it that's you know if you got a physical
body that's good for athletics you know
it and you you follow you play hockey or
you play baseball or whatever it is I
know I I have them in the palm of my
hand I know I'm God I know my way yeah
you know you know what you're supposed
to do okay so what I didn't tell you
yesterday and I'll just briefly say this
I was a college professor um for 14
years I was a terrible student when I
was in school now I was smart you mean
you were yeah you were a belligerent no
you were re you were against the school
uh I didn't love school at all I really
didn't like school but I wasn't
belligerent about it I was you did your
job I didn't per no I didn't I was a
terrible student oh my God didn't
perform um and you know I got poor
grades but maybe one out of five
teachers saw me and they thought I don't
know why this guy isn't doing the school
work but it doesn't really matter he is
smart and so they would break the rules
for me in some way they would make it
possible for me to get school so I got
through school I wasn't really capable
of doing the work it turns out I don't
know if dyslexia is a real thing but if
dyslexia is a real thing I have it and
it was getting in my way and it was
making it impossible for me to perform
which was then resulting in me being
punished for not performing and so
anyway I didn't like school it didn't
like me and that was my history and when
I got somehow through graduate school I
got my PhD and I became a college
professor it happened that I was
teaching in a school that the professor
was entirely free to teach any way that
they wanted to any subject liberal
Beyond liberal wow almost insane but
this was perfect for me because I wasn't
going to teach in a way that I would
have failed to learn I was going to
teach in a way that would have worked
for me and so I ended up being a teacher
for students who were smart but did not
perform well in school so that became my
specialty it wasn't you know you know
that life I know that it is possible to
teach students who are not made for
school and it sounds like you and I did
two different different versions of this
you you taught kids who uh got
themselves in trouble I taught kids who
weren't performing but anyway I want to
hear they need help yeah they need help
they need some teacher who actually
cares about them to do something
different than the other teachers have
done get them off that track yeah so
okay you have you're teaching 12th
graders these 12th graders are uh
troubled young boys um what did you do
how did you how did you teach a room
full of people who were constantly
getting in trouble okay first of all I
was teaching at the time in junior high
seventh
grade uh the the principal of the I mean
the head of the Mass Department in John
Mir Junior High they had they had to get
a teacher and and I was ready for the
junior high I had enough of sixth grade
and Martin they know I'm good at people
have problems learning and I can help
them so they gave me a bad but not not
bad emotionally but poor performers for
whatever reason and the kids like me
they so I'm good for that I got that job
so these are the 12th graders at Junior
High then the next promotion yeah Mr
Burl the superintendant moved me from
there to the continuation
school 12 I forgot 11 or 12 boys 12th
graders total
rexs one more
infraction
expulsion get out get out of our hair
yeah go to another school district to
take you and I said oh good this this is
my this is my golden opportunity and Mr
bur knew that he he knew me real well
and I'll tell you why because I gave
when he went to the hospital to get a
hernia operation no one came there with
any you know saying get well Mr Burl you
know what and I told my wife sesi I said
sesi you know I should take him a box of
candy and tell him I hope he gets well
and he's a nice man well go ahead that's
a good idea when I went there I gave in
the box of seiz candy you know seiz
Candy of course I gave him that and um
he was in the hospital laying in the bed
and he said Martin please don't tell me
any
jokes I just had a her don't want to
laugh I don't want to laugh and because
he knew what kind of a person I am and
he and I says Mr bur I hope you get what
thank he you know Martin no one has come
here to wish me well not that I'm
waiting for it but someone should have
said that superintendent come and say
Get Well Mr superintendent and he I
appreciate that that would help me and
I'll tell you why I didn't do it for
that purpose I just sure you know was
the right thing to do yeah I I wanted to
do it no one told me to do that I just
wanted to do it and um so we got he
liked me and um he thought I'd be a good
teacher for those bad boys and so he put
me in a room in the administration
building because they can't put him back
in the regular school and even in the
room as I at they're still in at school
right they put me in this room upstairs
in a building built in
1912 and called Lincoln School and the
rest of the building was Administration
secretaries Board of Education room it
was all administrative one little room
in the corner painted green because
green is supposed to make you calm is
that right I don't know if it does I've
heard it okay and night they gave me a
little office in the side and the boys
come in the first day now they come I'm
I'm nervous cuz I usually deal with
little kids you know sixth graders
seventh
graders and so they come in you know
like you know who in the hell is this
guy what's his name you know gig gig gig
what the hell you pronounce it you know
I don't know what's going through their
minds they put their feet up on the desk
they're dominating this room we're the
boss you're just a jerky pres
teacher L they know 5 years in the
logging camp in Canada I had barroom
brawls every Saturday I could pick these
guys up and boss them off the walls I
was 205 lbs then weigh 6 I was
6'1 34 years old Power never use it but
power so the guy in the back had you see
he lifted up weights you could tell by
the way he's built he had a a what do
you call it a diamond not wasn't Diamond
probably glass earring and he had a
tattoo and those days
1971 no student ever had tattoos or
earrings or you know here or there and
all that stuff so ah okay I said
boys I'm your teacher and here's my name
I put a g e g i a n first name is Martin
and I said I want you to look at that
name and you remember how to pronounce
it cuz I'll know every one of your names
by time you get out of this classroom
today and I'll memorize him clearly and
I know your face in this year and out
the other they don't care anything now
what I got to do I got I got to do
something to get their
attention the boy in the back the guy
that's like this I said come here he
wouldn't come at
first you know sulky come
here he gets up sers up I pushed it but
cleared my desk and I said I'm going to
arm wrestle
you if I put you
down class will stay here and you'll
follow my rules if you put me down class
is dismissed go
home these guys never heard of a teacher
talk like that in their
lives and I'm and I'm that's the way I
am that's my personality and it comes
out better with the bad boys than the
good
guys and these kids got all come on his
name was Elvis Elvis Hernandez
from uh Puerto
Rico uh we got my desk I clean the desk
up I said God the almighty pervading
intellect and when you're old as 34 you
are your endurance is greater than a
young man but his strength is greater in
the beginning than a even though I'm
strong if he puts me down the next two
or three seconds that's it but if he
goes 51 I've got to lead on that I know
that older you are the more endurance
you have but you have to have the power
too long story short I put them
down aha okay I said now listen to me
carefully now they're they're taking a
little notice yeah and this teacher this
they they can't fathom it they can't
digest it yet I'll tell you why you're
here you're not stupid a lot of you have
ability I can tell by looking at you
I've been in the teacher a long time I
can size you up you got ability you know
geni there might be even a genius here
for all I know and and I tell him you
know what I killed better people than
you and me in my lifetime I K hundreds
of like that people I never saw I
murdered them I told him bombing raay
you must have killed somebody better
than you a future Newton or whatever and
um so I got their attention and I said
here's the reason why you are in here
today and I'm making this all up now
there's no scientific or physiological
reason for this to happen you sit like
this slouch in your seat and you hunch
over like this and you I drew a picture
of the spinal cord and there's holes in
the middle of each vertebrae
yeah vertebrae vertebrae yeah and the
nerve goes through that hole into the
back of your head is a medulla yeah and
that that is brings the whatever you're
hearing it registers in your brain and
you and if you get to see pictures of
what you what you're doing mind pictures
and you get smarter and smarter and if
you sit up straight you that doesn't
Bend cause a short
circuit the electrical current in the
nerve won't get to the medulla or maybe
parts of so often go through you miss
the whole
show I'm not kidding you it took about
two weeks they got you like this and
some say Mr Gent is this right yeah
that's right that's good you know
confirmation I know I got him now I got
him in the palm of my hand
and
literally they were boys who never had a
childhood that that's that's what they
missed mm a little childhood like you
with your sons you grew up with them you
help them you tell them things to do and
they remember you and they thank you the
mother does something to help you and
it's a family Harmony there's no
friction
and so I became their father obviously
and their mother more than their mother
sometimes than the
father and so that
Elvis was in the detention home several
times I had to go to the juvenile
delinquent detention home and talk to
the guard please let the kid out this
time I'm his teacher I and okay Mr they
want you to keep him there and do
something with a kid they're not trying
to put him in prison yeah so long story
short he gradu uated from school high
from Lincoln High School so to every
other boy and your whole class the whole
11 of them mhm and they want to put
girls in my class too I said no I will
not take girls I can't react to girls
like I react to boys get another woman
teacher and I got a woman teacher uh PhD
in the psychology she worked in a prison
with young women perfect for the bad
girls they didn't hire her you know why
no
she was
fat PHD in physical in Psychology worked
in the prisons with tough women tough
young teenage girls yeah perfect for
these girls and I F Mr I won't mention
his name assistant superintendent of
personnel Martin he says you know did
you see her I said I saw her what what's
she has she wears men's
shoes I said
I won mention I know his name there's a
okay and I
said I took the paper in his desk I
rolled it up can I say a bad word oh
here okay oh absolutely R up I says
shove this up your
ass I walked out and the two secretaries
outside could hear everything and they
both did this to
me and so I got kicked out of that
school oh no yeah and put into regular
classrooms again and Mr Burl uh then
from then on other things happened but
Mr Burl was my Defender and anyways I
took care of one of the bad boys in the
in the sixth grade there that school I
was teaching at Mrs Reen and she say
Martin we're going to see the the movie
um Fantasia you ever see that movie I
have Symphony music Beautiful Walt
Disney's wonderful and he the local
theater will take
six carloads of buses from the school
and make a special 12:00 noon showing
and we can go you want to I sure I'll
join you in that but she say would you
watch this one kid I can't handle him
Danny Rogers
sure I sit behind him he's a bad kid
okay I grab him by the neck pull him out
of the chair get in the bus pull the bus
driver you watch him you have to have an
adult watch the student we saw the movie
now next thing I know I'm up for the
parents are coming home the p is the
truck driver come home they going to
have me
fired a mark on his neck oh parente lo
lo local pares that means you're the
parent at the time you were under your
but you're not supposed to yeah unless
you're protecting yourself
sure and they want my throat they want
me fired and you know Mr Burl's there
and the assistant superent School Mr
Alex Smith he hates my guts because
I'm yeah you know I'm not I'm not a
bully but I fight for what I
believe Mr BR here's the whole
thing Mark he gets he got up like he's
going to leave all way as if he heard
enough and the other guy lacky following
behind him and I he said Martin let me
tell you something I'll take care of you
don't you worry you won't be fired by me
I'll tell you that now for God's sake
when you go do something like that grab
the hair it doesn't leave any m
don't you know that I did that when I
was a teacher yourself long time ago
grabbing by the hair it leaves no Mark
and from then on I was King of the roost
so that's the kind of things
that they're not
luck who knows that candy who knows what
happened and that candy was not done for
any purpose right I mean I don't even
know but but okay so do you have any IDE
so you had oh wait yeah Elvis yeah I was
going to ask you about Elvis Elvis this
is 15 or so years later I'm in a in a
restaurant I'm eating a hot dog in a
root beer and there's a um the the
counter I'm sitting at it faces the
street and so I'm eating you know people
going in and out of the place and I hear
Mr aan I turn it's Elvis he starts
giving a talk to the people there this
is the greatest teacher in the world but
I said Elvis calm down calm down and
come on Al say grab you by the the hand
I dro the hot dog in the thing outside I
want you to meet my wife my little baby
and we go out in the car park there
she's a young girl you got a little baby
in her arms and um uh she says Mr
engaging in the morning Mr engaging at
night that's all I hear in our home and
I'm glad to meet you sir and I said
Elvis what are you doing look what he's
doing 45 I think it's was 45 men uh what
do you call it's a crew of men 45 that
in case of storms or things happen all
the electricity things are down this is
the emergency crew he's the
superintendent of all of
them he's the wow he's running a crew
he's learning a crew doing all this
expert man doing expert work that
everybody can't do you have to be
trained for that yeah dangerous work and
Elvis is cut out for that and now he's
taking all that energy yeah if we could
take Hitler and musolini and not Stalin
Stalin was going to become a a
seminarian you know you're going to be a
priest in the Georgian Orthodox church
and if you can and Hitler wanted to be
an artist that's all he wanted to do be
an artist his father said no no artist
he wanted to be an artist can you
imagine and if we could direct those
people if things happen and things go
and you end up that way maybe you could
have been some a criminal for all I know
I could have been something else who
knows what yeah but we come out things
happen not by luck not by chance not by
Randomness but by purpose well I don't
disagree with you I think that the
difference between you know maybe
occasionally there's a situation where
somebody is born defective but mostly uh
defective people are the result of
Developmental environments that aren't
enriching that don't reward the right
things and it creates defective what do
you mean well if you have if your
parents are broken let's say and your
parents uh let's say your parents are
obsessed with themselves or or they're
drunkers or they're drunkard yeah or
gamblers I got okay yeah if a poor
environment right a poor environment
causes the child to solve their own
problems and they may discover ways of
solving those problems that turn them
into monsters when they're adults so
yeah I don't see it as random at all I
see it as something that we should be
very focused on yes uh and you know it's
and Elvis is an example of that yeah
well you rescued him you know whatever
he was doomed yeah you know a tattoo and
a earring at that time unheard of yeah
1971 you said 71 maybe 72 I don't
remember but yeah yeah that was that was
way out of that was an indication that
he was headed down some bad Road and
what he needed was somebody to care
about him enough to hear what he was
about and to to guide him yeah and he's
the guy I wrestled with you know oh he
was yeah he's the one I put him down
yeah and he didn't like that at first
you know but anyway and by the way they
used to watch me when I come to in the
they' be in already in the room they
came to school early they like school so
much and I come down the hallway I say
hi to the secretaries as they come down
and and they my door is open and there's
a old fashion it's an old school a
bookcase with glass doors you know but
nothing in there and you could see my
reflection I mean I could they could see
me coming down the hallway coming close
to our door to come in and to be hiding
there like little kids yeah I walk in
the door they jump me and put me down
the floor
and gentle love caps yeah yeah boys boys
I my shirt my wife will kill me if I
oh they were they were children yeah
they were children well whatever they
were I mean they wanted to be children
again right they needed to go through
that and they needed somebody to care
very deeply about them and you know the
funny thing is we we don't understand
this anymore in our educational system
and we don't understand this as parents
that children you know we look at
children and we watch them break the
rules and we think that they want to
break the rules really what they want is
to find out what the rules are and they
want to know that somebody is paying
attention to the rules and then they're
going to help them right and so if you
are consistent with a child right and
you make good rules that aren't
arbitrary and you enforce those rules
the kid actually appreciates knowing
where the line is and that if they abide
by it things are okay look
at Brett that dog yes if you teach it
badly yeah look how loving that dog is
he knows this house is love yep I don't
know what the dogs call love in their
way of think but I can see in their eyes
they watching Everybody you went there
he want to know where you were going
when come back again is that that dog is
loved yeah you can tell the dog is not
nervous about anything nothing about
anything yeah what a I mean if your
children I saw your two boys nice Bo got
God Almighty you can't get any better
children you can't get you can't get
better kids and you know the funny thing
is Heather and I you will meet Heather I
will make sure that you do um Heather
and I did not know anything about
raising children when we had who does
well some people have children in their
family they've been around kids they've
watched okay but we didn't really either
of us have this and you know we kind of
looked at each other like neither of us
know what we're doing how are we going
to do this yeah and little anxiety sits
in sure yeah but it's good that anxiety
that means you're conscious and you want
to do something about it exactly and so
we just decided to you know the funny
thing is we decided to talk to our
children like they were adults from the
beginning at first it was almost a joke
right you know you talk to your child
like they're an adult it's amazing how
well that worked boy but that's the
credit goes to partly to you but more
credit to the children they they will
they rise to so you you have to always
this is works with students and children
you shoot above their heads and they
will rise to meet the challenge and if
you meet them at their level they don't
no because they they've got nowhere to
go they they know about that right they
they reasoned that a long time ago give
them something to shoot for yeah and
they make you smile make Mom and Dad
happy absolutely and go out we have
dinner this time outside instead of
eating the house little thing take a
little vacation or whatever yeah and the
other thing is and you point this out
with the dog and it works exactly the
same way with children they have to know
that nothing they're going to do is
going to result in you not loving them
you can be angry at them but they don't
have any insecurity about at the end of
the day whether you're on their team
100% they have a turn for that tough
love well not that tough but the term
the psychologists they use the term
attachment attachment secure attachment
okay and it's amazing if you make sure
that your kids have a secure attachment
and you do your best you'll never do a
perfect job but if you do your best to
give them a consistent set of rules so
that they can figure out what the rules
are right then that means husband and
wife working together 100% it can't be
comp you know yeah mama can I do this
did you ask your father no you ask your
father then I'll say what I'll say you
stick together then you can talk
privately right my dad told me once day
my mom and dad had an argument I I never
saw that I felt bad they're fighting bad
to each other after the thing was over
my mother said said to me my dad wasn't
there anymore he was out someplace
else visiting somebody he said Martin
don't remember your mama and I your dad
and I had a terrible argument but I want
you to know one thing you don't mention
this outside our home I still love your
dad and he loves me and that just well
sometimes that has to be that way she I
said okay Ma yeah you know we're not mad
at each other y we're just arguing she
he had his view I had my view now we
settled it yeah and she didn't create an
insecurity for you because you knew that
at the end of the day and I'm the only
child mind you I I felt bad I always had
a harmonious surroundings you know
anyways go ahead sure well um I wanted
to ask you before we finish up here um
your view
on uh
family uh you've told us a little bit uh
what did your dad do my dad was a first
a Ford motor Company employee um he had
a job he lived in Watertown uh when he
came from the the old country from he
was saved by American missionaries so
wait wait wait your father I know from
reading the uh paragraph um about your
book your father was an orphan made an
orphan tell that story mother and father
like the Jewish people got they got
slaughtered in their own home so your
father was an orphan from The Armenian
Genocide yeah okay his parents mom and
dad and baby sister only but maybe I'm
guessing couldn't walk yet I guess a
little baby and the brother was about 10
years
old all murdered yeah and he was and his
dad before the and and a Russ and a
German um a Turkish Sergeant was in that
same Village his family and my father's
family were friends and he was a special
had a high rank of a incit man's rank in
the Turkish Army very high um he had a
certain symbol on his hat Kal in fact
Kaplan the Jewish word Kaplan kapan is
there a Turkish Jews who are named
Kaplan oh I didn't know that yeah my
best friend when I was a little boy was
named Kaplan Kaplan is the Russian
Turkish word for gapan which means lion
interesting Kaplan is a word for Turkish
Gan is Turkish for Jew uh for Jewish
person's last name who lived in Turkey
yeah the Armenians have the first part
of their name are all Turkish words some
of them they put I in on the end you
know that becomes
uman that means a person who is
ingenious doing things Machinery or Goan
shoe maker Shoemaker
terak Tor T is a Taylor Yan son of a
Taylor my name isan in Armenian means
good
well well son good son son of good and
guess what my wife streets the Street's
name was my wife when I was quoting her
yeah was
Goodson in Armenian translation my last
name yeah that's is that something all
right well I have one for you as long as
we're uh talking coincidences before we
return to your story I told you my best
friend when I was a little boy uh named
Kaplan Aaron Kaplan okay uh he was a
great kid he was a bit wild um but
everybody loved Aaron everybody wanted
to be his best friend he was a a great
guy he died a few years ago of leukemia
which is very sad for me I we had long
since Grown Apart no negativity but we
just gone to opposite ends of the
country and and not stayed in touch very
much but um anyway
uh was I going to tell you about about
Aaron oh yeah here's the coincidence
Aaron was
born the same day not just the same date
but the same day of the same year as my
wife in same day same day same year
obviously the same number in the
calendar yeah yes April 26 1969 they
were both born in the same city I don't
I don't know what hospital Aaron was
born it's possible they were even born
in the same hospital um but anyway I
find that an interesting coincidence um
you know it took me a while to figure
out that that had happened but um but
anyway yeah Aaron is gone um but and he
uh he went on to be uh a doctor he was
quite a good doctor apparently um died
of leukemia after a long struggle with
it which I I uh even though we had not
seen each other in decades I made a
point of going to his his memorial
service see you you mention it's a
present coincidence yeah chance look you
see your your reasoning is is correct
according according to your philosophy
of Life yeah which is which is wonderful
you're sticking to that you're sticking
to your guns
but nothing is if you if you take the
word God yeah take it out for a minute
all prevail in intellect that's Admiral
Bird's word all preading intellect which
means God yeah he said he basically he's
a meteorologist and a very good one and
he's making all the universe he says is
rhythmic things move in harmony
everything is harmony it can't be chaos
if it's chaos it does it doesn't looks
like chaos but some Stars blow up that's
part of the harmony some stars are
extinguished
new moons come out or whatever it is y
this is all part of that no we can't go
beyond that cuz you say next thing you
say who created that well the thing is I
can make those arguments I don't need to
though I'm very comfortable with a world
of people who have a religious
perspective in fact the the funny thing
I grew up in a home that was very
secular we were Jewish uh you know we
celebrated Hanukkah Passover over but
not much more than that yeah um but my
friend Aaron was in a family that kept
kosher uh they had a Seder every
religious yeah and they invited me in so
you know I got to experience their view
of the world too and it meant a lot to
me you know it didn't it didn't really
change my Direction but it certainly um
made it very clear that people who I was
close with you know was really was my
second family for a little while um that
you know they had a very different view
of the way the universe worked and it
was just fine right we considered each
other's table and it was it was lovely
yeah they they weren't anti you you were
just excited to see what how these
people think yep that was that's
wonderful it was terrific and you didn't
say I'm not coming here anymore oh no no
you were excited I was I was you know I
didn't know to know as much as you can I
was too young to really realize what a
privilege it was to be included in their
their family rituals but I'm glad you
didn't say you were lucky to be you I
was too young to understand you said
that's okay that's I mean all of these
things you can rephrase it different any
way you want I know in my thinking I'm
glad you said it that way yeah all right
um let's see what else before we we've
talked a long time I have no idea how
long actually but um anything else uh
you think especially uh belongs here
well I had a lot of nice experiences in
teaching I did I'm a very
unorthodox clearly teacher yeah and I'm
even probably I'm an
unorthodox on this pod here your you are
an un unorthodox person yes I can see
that and I some I look like I'm
dominating somebody and I am not I'm
just excited yeah and I don't know how
to curtail my no I don't think you need
to no I mean I don't want I want to give
the other guy my teacher in School Mrs
short uh my math teacher in grade school
we had to go to the um teacher my mother
and father had to go to the because we
had three checks in
self-control our report card changed in
the elementary school was first 1 2 3 4
five means excellent good Fair poor
failure M and then they Chang it to u i
mean e excellent s satisfactory e uh U
unsatisfactory then say failure
unsatisfactory then they had a whole
list of Behavioral content
attentive uninterrupted good natured did
brought his HK check marks I got three
in self-control and my mom and dad want
know what's going on here self-control
so teacher parent night I went there
with my parents and and Mrs short my
math teacher she says Mr by the way
three checks were from three different
teachers of course one was the art
teacher too and by the way you know
Ivory soap sure Ivory soap comes it's a
white soap yeah Y and she wanted us to
bring one Ivory soap from home so we
could carve and make a polar bear in the
art class sure perfect for that and then
we could water it and smooth out the
skin and make a little she was a good
teacher and I was so hungry and my
depression I'm the heart of depression
and all my mom could make me was the
onion sandwich with mustard on it bread
mustard onion and if your mom was the
same as mine you have bread mustard
onion and we had a way in school we and
I met we
go
brother
onion anyways Mrs short said Martin is
in the last roow I was tall in the last
he's I I put the problem on the board
and whoever got the answer quick they
raise their hand he go Miss short Miss
short she'd be running up down the aisle
he almost had his hand in my face I want
me I got the answer and you know the
other kids got the they're not doing
that I'm I'm and and and she says at
least he didn't give me the answer he
just said Mr short he didn't give the
answer to the problem yeah and my dad
said well that's
something he didn't tell it to her but
he tell to my mom when we're walking
back home Martin at least didn't give
the answer but and then oh she's a
wonderful teacher and I loved her very
much Mrs short you said yeah Mrs short
and she was short red hair curly red
hair she very good teacher all the
teachers were good
this is not all mine this
[Music]
is any oh God anyways our literature
teacher we had a class for literature
where she read a book that you should
read and she explained the book it's in
our library boys and girls and they
introduced it encouraged to read and Mrs
is I okay and it was the charge of the
life
Brigade tennison's book poem what's the
one word in there out of the mouth of
Hell rode the 500 that was the British
hazards the men on Horseback the
Russians mowed them down they come out
of out of a mouth of Hell Rose the 500
and they wiped out that whole 500 the
word hell was in there right well we
kids sixth graders hell is a bad word
right it was that go to hell you know
and so we
say
Mrs I can't it's Whitney anyways Mrs
Jones yeah what she asked what do you
want me to repeat any poems yes that one
about the charge of the life Brigade and
so she read it out of the mouth we when
she hell we all
go she's swearing in
class with naive children you know yeah
no I I recognize it sure of course of
course all right you remember her name
huh the only reason I ask is because I
know from experience Wittier or W
Wittier I I could make up a name but in
my book I got the name you got it's in
your book well I was going to ask you
about your book wait let me
see no it's not in the book it's not in
the book Mrs oh oh we had a fresh air
camp in our fresh air room in our in our
school you know what that was no a
regular
classroom all the windows are open
and there's what you call uh what's the
windows on the Roof oh uh skylights
pardon skylights yeah but it was it
could open it up mhm let the in the
morning you came at
7:30 you lay on the military steel no
mattress just steel beds the little
springy and the pillow and boys and
girls us the girls end up going this way
and the boys going that way you lay down
and it quiet music would play on the
record and one of the kids would crank
the 78 RPM I never heard this 78 RPM oh
no I've heard that but I've never heard
of such a fresh air room oh yeah fresh
air class and we all breathe
in to get the fresh air and music is
playing meditation really that sounds
kind of healthy isn't that nice yeah
that's before you start class yeah okay
so my grandfather who you actually do
remind me of a fair amount um my
grandfather's a great guy uh he was a
tremendous influence on my brother and
me he was a chemist um he never he was
not an accomplished man in terms of he
never uh he was a a pollution control
inspector who got fired in The
Proposition 13 cutbacks in California
but he was a wonderful guy and in many
ways I think his accomplishment in life
was that he affected a great many young
people um not just me and my brother my
friends met him they adored him he was a
wonderful guy very funny and he also
took children very seriously any
question you would ask him he would do
his best to answer it at that level yeah
well no he would take your question
perfectly seriously and he would SCI he
would get too complicated to the kids
wouldn't understand what he's talking
about he he knew how to talk to yeah he
so he was sort of a born teacher that's
natural yeah he never he never taught
officially but he was was a born teacher
and so anyway young people loved him
because where other adults would ignore
them he would take them seriously and
answer their questions and and all of
that and why was I talking to you oh
yeah um you mentioned 78 records one of
the things that my grandfather did in
his career he worked for a number of
different companies he worked for shik
safety razor company uh he worked in the
formation of dental polymers uh for
dental work but one of of the things he
did is he worked for
RCA on vinyl when records went from
lacquer to vinyl he worked on the
polymers that they used in those first V
yeah exactly so you're talking about the
era of Records before that um he's hand
cranked 78 RPM he had to crank the
machine and you know catch it before it
dies out yeah you yeah so anyway my
grandfather just and those records if
you don't want them you know at the time
said well I heard that record long
enough you taking hot
water what it was made of I don't know
to this day you said lacquer lacquer I
think yeah you could shape it into a
bowl you could yeah oh my goodness and
plug the hole and move the soft part of
the and you you put flowers in it oh
wild I didn't know that I didn't know
that and I learned all
my in that book I was raised on
Beethoven Mozart
uh gy Ki the opera singer
medon uh
and uh Igor shapin the great Russian be
Bass the Russians all are good in Bass
music because their gut sounds of their
language deep you know the vulg bman the
song and all that and and so I knew
about the wars my grandpa told me all
the wars this that the generals and the
heroes my Grandma couldn't read or write
even an Armenian couldn't even you know
the farm person yeah women never got
educated at all and she would memorize
all the Bible Parables of Jesus and I
sit in front of her on a rocking chair
and grandma what tell me some more you
know Parables and she see I
showed I'm not saying I'm great but no
boy my age would do that but my grandma
made me want to do it yeah I loved her
so much and I wanted her to talk to me I
might learn something what was her name
pardon what was her name oh turfa tufa
turfa
marosan now I don't know turfa is not I
don't know if that's an Armenian name it
might be a Turkish name because in
Turkey like the Jews of Germany have a
German name yeah and the je Jews in
Poland have a Polish name and but Turk
in Armenia the Armenians had a Turkish
first part of the name but the last I
meant Armenian nothing else so some
German Jews you don't know what they're
German or Jews or what they have a
German name yeah so in Armenia the Ian
and if in my grandpa's when he was a boy
he said if you spoke Armenian in public
they cut your tongue out they did that
wow yeah and he said I was I go outdoor
Barber cut my hair and some give you a
shave I want to be sported up he passes
by know I'm Armenian they say what are
you doing there init I'm skinning a dog
and I said
Grandpa let him do his work he cuz he
could make a raise your slip and you're
dead and no one
cares that's right okay um so before we
close this uh your father folks I hope
you interested all this yeah no I bet
they will be um tell me this is the
chance to tell your mother and your
father's story I think it's important um
because so much of what life was like is
lost and you're 100 years old there
aren't and I know what happened there
aren't very many people who are 100
years old and the number of people who
are 100 years old who are loed the way
you are is very very tiny by the way the
veteran Veterans Administration yeah I I
got a letter about two years ago there's
only four B7 Pilots left there are only
four B7 Pilots left B7 specific
specifically yeah four of them left four
three or four years ago yeah and I'm
sure I'm I'm one of the last ones maybe
yeah you've might be the last one but
there's
183,000 World War II veterans left all
kinds Marines Sailors whatever it is y
183 out of 16 million
wow okay so your dad orphaned by The
Armenian jide yes how and the man who
did the most work for it was a Jewish
man you know who he was no uh
Henry morgantha you ever hear of him I
don't think so Henry morgantha was a
very brilliant Jewish
financier and during um W Wilson's
Administration he was I mean sorry
Roosevelt's been Administration he was
made Secretary of the Treasury and on
those bills is written Henry Morgan you
know when they sign on the bill sure the
next treasury guy he puts his name on it
yeah and but during the World War I he
was Ambassador to Turkey
and he has written a book called the
murder of a
Nation by Henry morgantha and he was a
one the greatest supporter for Armenians
and he got many
Armenians out of turkey in Danish and
what call Danish orphanages German
orphanages the
German um what do you call Missionaries
in Turkey they were for the Armenians
100% against the the Germans who were
ing the Turks see turkey was part of the
German in a austral Hungary fighting the
Russians and the zarus Russia Imperial
Russia and France and England that was
the allies before we came into the war
1917 anyways my my my
Dad wait was I I was trying to get you
to tell me your dad was rescued how was
your dad rescued yeah he was he was
a the I as too I don't want
bore the people the book will explain it
very easy but basically he was saved by
two American missionaries husband and
wife and I know this I'm making this
part up and not lying but I know he was
saved how he was saved and who the names
were my dad ever sat down and said
here's what I never even had that I made
it okay so he's saved by two
missionaries and it's a true TR it's a
true incident but maybe it didn't happen
like that maybe the fish you caught was
40 in long I said 80 in Long okay but
what happens to him after he's rescued
oh I had to stay in the in the mission I
couldn't I mean he couldn't stay he
couldn't get out cuz the Turks out there
would kill him yeah and um oh so they
brought him into the mission he stayed
in there a year and a half he learned
English pretty nice with always an
accent my dad has a hard
time to not speak English without an
accent yeah he's he's very smart man
yeah but that's one of his weaknesses
language pronunciation some people come
here when they're 25 years old they
speak fluid English after a while you
can't even tell if he's a foreigner or
not yeah but my dad he's America you
know blah hence the title of your book
yeah God Bless America America I said
Dad America no America I forget he say
you know okay so your dad saved he stays
in the mission yeah he learned English
good enough and he also uh loved the
National Geographic magazine and he used
to read that in the in the my grand dad
said that it tell you all about America
Cowboys Indians back in 19 you know what
it's 14 you know America was still
Indians some states weren't even States
territories Arizona and New Mexico 1912
they became States anyhow uh he read
that he loved National Geographics
crocodiles in alligators in Florida wild
Indians and this and that he couldn't
wait to see that country and imagine
imagination of a young child growing it
out of proportion and so he got to he
decided to leave and They begged him not
to
leave not to leave the the safety of the
of the compound American Mission
American flag is up there the Russ the
before America entered the war the Turks
didn't dare go in that I mean it and
thanks to Henry morgantha who did very
behind the scenes and he was able to
talk to all the Cel Pasha an Pasha all
the big sh who ran the the genocide cuz
he's American ambassador to Turkey he
has high rank
anyways he gets tells him I'm going to
leave please I love both of you but I
have to go to America I want to go and
they try to convince him we're going to
leave here sooner or later but why you
wait impetuous young man and he
confident in himself so they they give
in they pack him up a little cheese and
apple and bread they give him a $10 bill
my dad I remember he told me a $10
American Bill and some Turkish leas they
got L of Turkish money and Little Packet
stuff and kissed them all they're all
crying he left somehow he got down to
Tbone it's on the Black Sea and got onto
a ship I won't go to the details I take
all day but he swam lot of obstacles he
overcame him
got on the and it's an Argentinian ship
they spoke Spanish he thought it'd be an
American ship because America hadn't the
war yet yeah but a lot of German ships
there and they and the you know the
Jacob's letter J Jacob's letter is that
thing they put down on a boat yeah it
come to a row boo you get up in the L
that was up and here's the B dark
evening cold water this young kid with
with a basket all his uh food to eat and
his hat yeah all and the in a in a
document saying uh we are the
missionaries this is our one of our boys
take good care he's a very good boy and
blah blah blah blah official seal and
set in his he had it covered in um oil
cloth and wax melted camera seal it so
it wouldn't get wack and official seal
of the of the mission and that was all
safe and he got on the ship and they
were going to go to Bor first
um the Azor and then the Bor airis yeah
and so they got to the aor and he had my
dad got uh like a flu or some kind he
couldn't he had to have a doctor's care
and rest so he got off the boat and he
was there for I don't know how long I I
think I made it four weeks in the book
or something I this part I make up and
then American ship come in the Roma I
got that book I mean the in the budy of
mine looked in the in the computer and
got the ship with the passenger list and
my dad's name was on it wow you found
that anyways that boat went to Newport
News Virginia it's an American ship and
I and the Roma is the name of the ship
but the the president I mean Captain I
made him G gespi Captain Gillespie come
on board son they wel loaded with
immigrants and no charge just take them
save save their lives they come to going
to they want all looking for the Statue
of Liberty they didn't see it Newport
News Virginia there's no no Statue of
Liberty right and so anyway from then on
he went his the missionary said
Watertown Massachusetts there a lot of
Armenians there they came here in the
early 1800s I mean
1880s and go there first and they'll
help you they hugged each other
tearful bad moment my dad gets there
follow into the right right priest in
the church took him to the right
lady brother and sister the parents had
died and they were in their 40s and
brother brother was 45 or 42 and she was
a little younger than him they took him
in like a son and he became Mom and Dad
wow and they just love and he loved them
but he always my dad would say sometime
we slept in the same room together
my mom couldn't stand his snoring I mean
I mean snoring yeah and I just I go to
sleep I'm a young kid and and in his
sleep he'd say mik mik mother mother oh
mik he cry in his
sleep he was a grown man he's got a
family sure affected him so you think he
was crying for the mother that he lost
or the people who who raised him or who
took him in yeah he he loved them he
wanted a mother so bad and Rose and
George the brother and sister Rose was a
never married and she's about 45 at the
time I guess I'm just guessing yeah and
she's very fat and I'm not no overweight
I put him muscular arms and the brother
was a Shoemaker and they had the store
in the front and the home in the back
and um he grew up there and then from
there he got a small job make some money
little lot of nice interesting you'll
know about at the time Christmas on the
trees there's no electric light bulbs
candles and you had to be very careful
yeah I bet you did and that candle was
set on a little thing that you squeeze
on the TW on the branch and lay the
candle and it light it and and my mom
told me that she was in Troy at the time
I know they would know that they didn't
know each other at that time at all the
the Stallions at the fire department you
know you pump it by hand yeah the um
many fires going on in town could you
know yeah so this horses were ready and
so anyway he comes to
America then from then on he um Ford
motor has a ad now I don't know if this
is how it's happened but I have to make
it up on facts yes but it's not I it's a
narrative on true facts I'm making up
the story how did he get that job he's
he read it in the paper that I figur
that's what he did my dad never told me
all these things yeah but the story is
based on true it says Ford Motor Company
is looking for these following people
who speak these language about 12
languages German Italian whatever it is
Armenian in them and the interview for a
job in Detroit Ford Motor Company
employee relations uh job and had to be
a foreign a employee so I'm Armenian
let's say my dad and you're Armenian and
you got your wife just can hardly speak
English maybe and I want to know come in
there and talk to you and look around
check this is this is Ford yeah his way
is his home
clean oh I see you have a new couch very
nice that means he spend the money
wisely and today you call that what
meddling yeah so your dad was hired to
figure out which ERS yeah and and the
German guy was for the German and the
Italian for the Italian the Greek for
the Greek huh never heard of such and
also yeah and Ford gave each employee
one acre of his own land to grow a
vegetable farm really so he could have
fresh vegetables huh now Ford is a very
strict man I mean people hate him cuz he
didn't like Jews very much yeah he
didn't and he didn't like the no he not
Jews Jewish Bankers he hated the people
heed all bankers and he his his greatest
employee he had was a Jew Albert Khan an
architect and he just thought he was the
greatest man in the world but the
bankers he hated their guts but here's a
man come up with bootstraps no education
he cut the idea of mass production y he
didn't invent the automobile just
Germans invented the automobile the
assembly line d d Benz and Porsche came
later anyways my dad I mean at that job
and he goes to the Armenian homes or
you're Greek go to the Greek homes and
that was his job and he had a chance to
they gave him an automobile fact company
car he passed that test too and in the
in the back in Water Town they made sure
that he could drive the car before he
went there so manyways everybody helped
him yeah met my mom got married and that
was it and my grand
in those days you don't just take a girl
out yeah yeah you got to go to go
interrogation I mean interrog the Nazi
the Gusto couldn't do that good my
grandpa was how's your health how much
money you got are you strong what's
what's your religious belief and my dad
was he said I'm Protestant in Armenia is
Protestants and Protestant you have the
Armenian my but these people my friends
I what do you call
Presbyterians I don't care I'm Armenian
I'm I'm Armenian Orthodox and what
political
party you had to
be Social
Democrat that's a national International
party Germans had social Democrats
Hitler hated them and they're more
socialist but more liberal yeah and he
he belonged to the tashak which was like
equivalent to Super nationalist
and so my grandpa saids no good he says
I'll change whatever you want I don't
care about those I want your daughter
right anyway that's how they got married
and had me and and my mom lost every and
the brother my uncle her brother died
the moment I was born in the same
hospital he had a 10-year-old brother
younger than
herself and two of the sisters had died
in uh new Troy New York buried there and
the last two my mom and her little
brother martin he died and they named me
Martin because wow same name is my her
my uncle he died in the same Hospital
same down the I don't know where same
Hospital wow Herman kefir Hospital in
Detroit it's a very famous Hospital in
Detroit Herman keer huh I don't know it
yeah it's still I think still there
anyways it's such a
nice I'm biased let's face it I see it
as the epitome of what I believe how
about what I went through
imagine I would hear records of Great
opera singers um uh music and history
and and religion and love and care I
I I and I wasn't ever ashamed many
Armenians like Teran is an Armenian name
terak is a t r TZ o k terak means a
tailor in Turkish so if you're born in
turkey that your last name is
Teru you say
Teran that means you're Armenian but
you're from turkey and so my name is
pure Armenian my grandfather's name p
marosan maros is the Armenian name means
martyr a man who dies for a cause sure
and so I come from that kind of a the
other Armenians are all Armenians they
have a Turkish name though in the FR
part the Yan is on the end and if you're
from Russia Armenia or communist Armenia
it's
Yan and if you're from Turkish Armenia
it's Ian now anyways how much of your
family story is it just your father's
story in your book is it what is it only
your father's story in your book my mom
my me my father grandpa the times
President Roosevelt everything the World
War II World War I Heroes Purple Heart
by dad got and the what do you call it
the Silver Star for bravery yeah okay
well I am it's a good story I am hoping
that people are going to listen to this
and they're going to buy your book it
has very good reviews I looked at it uh
online and I've actually ordered a copy
myself
um by the way it's not a book that you
ever read a novel about that thick yeah
you know 200 three I mean 2,000 pages
and you at the Third 300th page you see
um Joe Johnson you say who was Joe
Johnson you have to go back and figure
out was he the son or the brother or you
get confused there's so many names
volume and you'll get no fun out of that
mine is not that way yeah you can read
it and you're reading you're in the book
yeah well the reviews do suggest it is
an excellent very readable book the book
is and by the way I didn't know that
reviews were in there you showed it to
me five star right absolutely I I don't
have a computer folks you don't have a
computer you don't have a phone you uh I
have no no television driving yourself
at 100 which I find shocking and
impressive um but anyway the book is God
Bless America America spelled with a k
at the end not ta but ka ka so anyway
check out God Bless
America and you will get the story any
bookstore yeah any bookstore um if they
don't have it they can order it yeah
they can order it um so uh Martin and
grian it has been a pleasure talking to
you um I am sure we could go on for many
many hours and I don't think there's any
end to how many stories you've got Brett
I I right now you made me feel about 21
years old I'm
so excited and like I'm not I'm not a
100 you're not 100 I feel like I'm just
in Turkish
Anu which means Anna means mother
golu means
Born Again of a new mother i' I've been
reborn to be my youth I feel so happy
and so youthful so naive you know all
the things that youth means to people
and I feel confident you've made me feel
I you made my day today great I'm I'm
going to be 105 before I die because of
him hell yeah all right well I I look
forward to part two of the conversation
uh it's been a real pleasure than here
BR thanks for joining us everybody
byebye everybody don't take any wooden
nickels out I don't think they circulate
those anymore all right oh jeez great
thank you very great job it's been
[Music]
wonderful